mes chers collègues donc nous allons
poursuivre l'examen du projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 donc depuis lundi
matin nous avons examiné
360 amendements et il ne nous en reste
plus que
5143 amendements à examiner donc
inutile de vous dire que nous n'irons
pas jusqu'au bout
alors
nous reprenons avec
amendement portant article additionnel
après article 2 amendement
identique
oui allez-y monsieur le député
bonjour madame la Présidente chers
collègues
nous avons hier passé en revue tous les
moyens de de
promouvoir le travail des seniors je
reviens juste sur cette question là en
disant que
il est quand même difficilement
concevable de penser que en obligeant
les gens à travailler on crée de la
richesse il y a quelque chose de
complètement aberrant à penser que
l'offre de travail va créer la demande
si nous n'augmentons pas les salaires et
le SMIC de toute façon la demande ne
sera pas là pour justifier ses emplois
que vous voulez forcer voilà bon
maintenant c'est pour cet amendement
nous nous sommes pour faire contribuer
les plus riches à cet effort qui permet
d'équilibrer nos régimes de retraite
et vous vous souvenez que
l'ISF ayant été
abandonnés
ils ne profite que à une poignée de de
nos compatriotes là où des besoins
énormes se font sentir pour financer les
retraites et donc nous proposons tout
simplement un rétablissement de l'ISF
qui n'aurait dû être qu'une mesure de
salubrité publique et qui n'a toujours
pas été faite malgré nos différentes
demandes sur le PLF et le plfs donc
cette ISF nous permettrait largement de
compenser les les sommes que vous
prétendez trouver en déficit dans
quelques années donc vous voyez on
anticipe nous aussi et
cet amendement vise à rétablir un impôt
juste puisque de toute façon
la vocation de l'impôt et de procéder à
une répartition plus juste des richesses
parce que avec votre logique finalement
autant supprimer tous les impôts si
finalement on a plus besoin de l'impôt
distributif redistributif autant le
supprimer et bien nous nous sommes pour
que chacun contribue à la hauteur de ses
moyens de façon à ce que tout le monde
en profite selon ses besoins donc voilà
un amendement très simple pour établir
l'ISF une mesure de salubrité publique
vous savez ce que c'est et bien c'est ce
que pèse les 10 plus grosses fortunes de
France donc ça donne le vertige je
trouve et c'est d'ailleurs tellement
énorme qu'on a même du mal à imaginer
les actionnaires ont également de quoi
se réjouir parce que l'ensemble des
dividendes représentent 259 milliards en
2021 et les riches ils continuent donc à
s'enrichir et cette richesse elle est
bien bien loin de ruisseler jusqu'au
travailleur et travailleuse
d'autres chiffres qui font moins rêver
885 c'est le revenu avec lequel la
moitié des pauvres vivent ou plutôt
survivent 11 millions c'est le nombre de
pauvres de personnes pauvres en France
plus de la moitié de ses pauvres sont
des femmes donc deux poids de mesure et
qui le gouverneur et à qui le
gouvernement demande de faire des
efforts en travaillant plus longtemps et
bien les travailleurs et travailleuses
alors même que les plus riches payent 2
à 3 fois moins d'impôts que les 10% les
plus pauvres par cet amendement nous
proposons donc le rétablissement et le
renforcement de l'ISF
très bien merci amendement suivant
allez-y madame la députée merci madame
la Présidente donc dans son dernier
rapport Oxfam nous apprenait qu'au cours
des 10 dernières années les
milliardaires ont multiplié leur fortune
par deux il disait aussi qu'il suffirait
de taxer la fortune des milliardaires
français à hauteur de 2% seulement pour
financer les 12 milliards de déficits
hypothétiques sur lequel le gouvernement
voudrait aujourd'hui nous faire pleurer
et surtout pour lequel il nous faudrait
sacrifier collectivement 2 ans de nos
vies nous proposons donc une mesure
alternative de justice sociale
totalement indolore pour l'immense
majorité de la population le retour de
l'impôt sur la fortune dont le retrait
nous coûte obamo 4 milliards par an sans
aucune contrepartie positive pour les
gens ni en termes d'emploi ni en termes
d'investissement
et souvenez-vous en mars 2022 Oxfam et
Greenpeace publié un rapport qui
montrait que le patrimoine financier des
63 milliards français et mettaient
autant de gaz à effet de serre que celui
de 50% de la population française notre
dispositif prévoit par conséquent une
majoration pour les contribuables dont
le patrimoine et le plus polluant et à
ce sujet j'ajoute un élément dont on
parle peu tout le monde l'a compris
derrière votre projet il y a bien sûr
l'incitation à la retraite par
capitalisation or les fonds de pension
investissent massivement si si tout à
fait
massivement leurs actifs dans les
industries les plus polluantes et
notamment petrochimiques alors où chaque
rapport scientifique est plus alarmant
que le précédent en ce qui concerne le
dérèglement climatique et ses effets ce
projet qui consiste à nous faire
travailler plus produire plus toujours
plus longtemps reste dans une logique
productiviste et extractiviste à rebours
complet des enjeux d'aujourd'hui c'est
bien nous qui allons dans le sens de
l'histoire en réclamant la diminution du
temps de travail et le retour à la
retraite à 60 ans avec 40 annuités non
seulement du progrès social mais en plus
c'est prouvé scientifiquement cela
entraîne mécaniquement une baisse
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre et de
notre empreinte carbone votre
proposition est rétrograde et dangereuse
et les 2,8 millions de personnes qui ont
envahi les rues hier l'ont bien compris
nous proposons donc ici de rendre l'ISF
aux Français dans un dispositif renforcé
qui tient compte de l'impact écologique
merci je demande la vie donc de la
rapporteur sur ces trois amendements
merci madame la Présidente bonjour à
toutes et tous alors on reprend un débat
qu'on a qu'on a déjà eu dans le cadre du
dernier PLFSS mais et PLF qui est de
rétablir l'impôt sur la fortune je
rappelle déjà nous là on parle supprimer
mais transformer en impôts sur la
fortune immobilière en 2018 vous voulez
une nouvelle fois créer une nouvelle
fiscalité sur le capital je vous invite
à lire le rapport du comité indépendant
piloté par France stratégique qui
indique que la France est parmi l'un des
pays
dans lequel la fiscalité du capital est
la plus forte je rappelle aussi que
depuis la réforme de l'ISF on observe
une baisse des expatriations et une
hausse du retour vers la France ce qui
est important puisque ça accroît les
recettes fiscales je serai donc
défavorable à ces amendements
très bien alors j'ai quelques demandes
de parole madame madame Rousseau vous
avez la parole merci madame la
Présidente vous dites que la France est
un des pays où la taxation du capital
est la plus importante pour autant c'est
aussi un des pays où les inégalités de
patrimoine et de patrimoine financiers
et non financier explose et ont explosé
sous le mandat d'Emmanuel Macron je
rappelle qu'aujourd'hui et selon le
calcul qui a été fait notamment par
roxfam mais pas que le taux d'imposition
des
0,01% les plus riches et de 2%. donc
quel pays qui se revendique des droits
humains de l'égalité et qui met ce mot
au fronton de tous ces bâtiments publics
dans quel pays qui se revendique donc de
l'égalité peut-on accepter un taux
d'imposition des 0,01% les plus riches à
2%. ça n'existe pas en fait est-ce que
vous faites là c'est de faire exploser
les inégalités pour que notre pays
ressemble aux États-Unis mais en fait
nous avons un modèle social qui est très
différent de celui des États-Unis et
nous en sommes fiers en fait de ce
modèle social c'est celui-ci que nous
essayons de sauver aujourd'hui je
rappelle aussi que vous avez supprimé 5
euros sur les APL des plus fragiles
diminuer leurs allocations chômage fait
travailler les personnes au RSA et qu'en
fait
cette politique cette espèce de guerre
larvée contre les pauvres et bien à un
moment donné va se retourner contre vous
j'espère que ce sera pour la réforme des
retraites
très bien monsieur Clouet s'il vous
plaît on s'écoute merci beaucoup madame
la Présidente alors pour que pour que
tout le monde soit je pense dans ma
méthode d'esprit on est d'accord qu'hier
on a discuté l'index seniors donc qui
servait à décorer votre texte s'en
servir à autre chose que cela et
malheureusement vous n'avez pas souhaité
qu'on enrichisse pour donner malgré vous
un sens et une portée à ce que vous avez
inventé aujourd'hui on passe au coeur du
sujet l'argent car vous nous dites c'est
la raison pour laquelle on est là
aujourd'hui vous nous dites il faut
trouver 12 milliards d'euros pour les
caisses de retraite alors ça se discute
il y a beaucoup de scénarios du corps
vous avez pris le pire mais admettons
admettons on va être de bonne
compositions parce que nous sommes
vraiment dans une logique de
co-construction comme vous le savez vous
voulez trouver 12 milliards d'euros bon
on va pas tortiller il y a deux
solutions il y a deux solutions pour
trouver 12 milliards d'euros soit
l'impôt sur la vie on reporte l'âge de
départ des milliers de gens vont décéder
avant de pouvoir liquider leur pension
ou bien il est elles seront en pension
en invalidité n'arriveront plus à faire
les petits gestes du quotidien faire la
cuisine laver le le domicile s'amuser
avec les petits enfants etc première
option moins de retraités vivants de
l'argent économisé deuxième option
trouver les 12 milliards là où ils sont
ailleurs et on va vous proposer toute la
journée c'est le sens des amendements
qui arrivent une série de sorties de
secours pour trouver ces deux milliards
d'euros dans les hauts revenus dans les
grandes fortunes dans les cotisations
des plafonnés bref avoir des moyens
pérennes et durables d'alimenter le
système de retraite dès lors prendre un
ou deux de nos amendements dans la
journée permettra de répondre à ce qui
nous préoccupe voire même de retirer le
texte de loi comme ça on en reste là on
repart tous bons amis on a trouvé de
l'argent on évite de facturer aux
travailleurs de ce pays votre réforme et
on aura même mis un peu d'argent de côté
dans les caisses de retraite et ce qui
est même formidable avec ces amendements
c'est que si vous en prenez un ou deux
vous équilibrez le système mais si vous
en prenez trois ou quatre on pourra
revenir à la retraite à 60 ans donc
voyez il y a une marge de progression
qui est tout à fait considérable et
aujourd'hui on vous prend gros mots vous
voulez 12 milliards et ben vous avez le
choix entre le peuple et vos amis
très bien la parole est à Monsieur non
s'il vous plaît on commence pas par
s'applaudir on n'est pas au théâtre
Monsieur Didier Martin vous avez la
parole
merci madame la Présidente bonjour à
tous et à toutes on va aborder le sujet
de fond sur effectivement cet équilibre
des retraites vous avez mis l'enjeu en
évidence il nous manque 12 à 13
milliards d'euros et nous avons des
solutions qui ne sont pas les solutions
que vous proposez pourquoi
premièrement parce que nous sommes
fidèles au principe de la répartition
nous souhaitons que l'activité le
prélèvement sur l'activité servent à
financer et à servir des retraites bien
méritées de ceux qui ont travaillé et
qui ont payé à leur tour en leur temps
pour ceux qui étaient en retraite à
l'époque donc ça ce principe il est tout
à fait affirmé et c'est le principe de
la répartition que nous voulons défendre
si nous allons autre part que sur la
répartition ce sera peut-être la
capitalisation mais je ne pense pas que
niveau ni nous ne souhaitions pousser
vers la capitalisation alors vos
solutions aux solutions elles sont
extrêmement innovantes et nous les
entendons depuis des années c'est à dire
plus d'impôts plus de prélèvements
obligatoires ce n'est pas notre option
ce n'est pas notre option nous ne
souhaitons pas et les mesures que nous
avons prises que ce soit pour les
ménages ou pour les entreprises ce n'est
pas augmenté ni les prélèvements
obligatoires ni les impôts
4 milliards sur l'ISS c'est le chiffre
que j'ai entendu on est loin du compte
par rapport au 12 au 13 qui manquent
pour l'équilibre notre mesure avec la
mesure d'âge article 7
générera environ 18 milliards d'euros ce
qui nous permet d'avoir un gap un
supplément de 4 à 5 milliards d'euros
pour payer des mesures de justice
sociale mesure de justice sociale qui
nous permettent de lutter contre la
pauvreté et depuis plusieurs années ce
qui n'était pas parmi nous je le
rappelle nous avons un plan de lutte
contre la pauvreté et bien ces mesures
de lutte contre la pauvreté les femmes
seules les carrières hachées les
personnes qui ont hélas pas assez de
trimestre pour arriver à l'âge de
retraite qui dépassent les 67 années de
travail et bien tout cela nous voulons y
mettre un terme avec cette ce
prélèvement supplémentaire qui arrive
sur le travail et pas sur les impôts ni
sur les
les charges des entreprises
[Musique]
vous avez la parole
oui madame la Présidente mes chers
je nous invite collectivement à prendre
la mesure de l'importance de la journée
qui s'ouvre devant nous puisque après
l'article 2 nous allons
examiner
un certain nombre de propositions
alternatives pour assurer l'équilibre du
régime de retraite et je pense que nous
allons avoir des débats qui seront à la
frontière de la politique et de la
technique mais ils seront éminemment
politique puisque il y a deux visions
du partage des richesses et ça vient
d'être rappelé avec beaucoup de
sincérité par Didier Martin à l'instant
qui s'oppose à l'occasion de ce débat
sur le régime des de retraite
vous avez posé un postulat qui
consistait à dire que pour équilibrer un
déficit dont nous ne contestons pas la
réalité on peut discuter de son ampleur
et de sa durée mais nous ne contestons
pas le fait qu'il y a au moins pour un
temps un déficit conjoncturel et face à
cette situation vous avez admettons même
25 ans admettons même on parle de on
parle de des retraites pour plusieurs
générations et donc ce qu'on va devoir
faire aujourd'hui c'est essayer de vous
convaincre et à travers vous convaincre
l'ensemble des Français mais j'ai le
sentiment qu'ils ont déjà entendu le
message qui est que entre le choix de
l'impôt sur la vie parce que vous dites
vous ne voulez pas augmenter les impôts
vous en décidez un qui est celui de
faire travailler deux ans de plus
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens et la
palette des solutions que nous vous
proposons et bien il y a un choix
politique
et moi je souhaite qu'on puisse aller le
plus loin possible dans l'examen de ces
différentes propositions la première
d'entre elles qui est mentionnée qu'elle
rétablissement de l'ISF alors on peut
s'interroger de savoir comment ça se
plug sur un projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale mais peu importe
peu importe dire qu'on peut aller
chercher 4 milliards d'euros pour
financer l'ensemble des dépenses
publiques et ce faisant dégager de la
marge de manœuvre pour les retraites
c'est une proposition pertinente la
parole est à Monsieur Monet
merci madame la Présidente vous dites
souvent que vous voulez sauver le
système par répartition
moi je pense que vous allez vous allez
l'asphyxier ce système par répartition
pourquoi la gestion d'un système par
répartition c'est ni plus ni moins que
la gestion de déséquilibre
qui conduit soit des déficits soit des
excédents
néanmoins ce système est toujours
alimenté c'est pour ça qu'il est
intéressant
il y a deux approches dans la gestion de
ces déséquilibres
la vôtre qui consiste à contraindre les
dépenses sans toucher les recettes
contraindre les dépenses ça veut dire
moins de retraite
ce que vous êtes en train de proposer
vous ne touchez pas les recettes vous
contraignez les dépenses uniquement les
dépenses nous on a une démarche inverse
c'est ça notre divergence de fonds c'est
que nous on veut stimuler les recettes
pour avoir les dépenses qui
correspondent aux besoins de la
population et c'est en ça que je pense
que votre approche va asphyxier le
système par répartition et la note va la
revivifier puisque tout compte fait on
n'a pas la même approche parce qu'on n'a
pas tout à fait le même projet de
société
très bien monsieur le député monsieur
Gernigon
oui merci madame la Présidente j'aurais
revenir sur la taxation des super riches
ou des ultra riches quand on madame
Rousseau dit 2%. je crois que là il y a
un gros souci dans les paramètres qui
sont pris en compte dans ce calcul
comment dire les Ultra riches payent
l'impôt sur les sociétés comme tout le
monde paye l'impôt sur le revenu comme
tout le monde et au-delà de 2% 2% en
fait c'est le montant de l'impôt payé
par rapport à leur patrimoine bien
prenons un ménage modeste qu'il y a une
maison qui voit une béton 300.000 euros
qui va payer 2000 euros d'impôts bah si
on fait le calcul de Madame Rousseau ce
couple ne paye qu'au 66% d'impôts donc
c'est pas le calcul à retenir il faut
pas raconter n'importe quoi
très bien monsieur Bazin
merci madame la Présidente
moi je veux ma clé à la question posée à
travers cet amendement qui est celle du
patrimoine des retraités et des futurs
retraités et la situation actuelle c'est
que finalement on a eu une évolution de
la fiscalité ces dernières années qui a
plutôt pénalisé ce qui était
propriétaire avec les filles avec la
taxe foncière dans des choix qui ont été
faits et la question du patrimoine des
retraités notamment de classe moyenne
un lien avec l'impact sur le pouvoir
d'achat des retraités aujourd'hui 90%
des plus de 60 ans vivent chez eux et
74,9% des retraités sont propriétaires
ce qui est bien supérieur à la moyenne
de toute la population qui a 58% et et
même si on regarde les non retraités qui
seront des futurs retraités seulement
50% sont des propriétaires de leur
logement or on sait bien que quand
arrive la retraite finalement un départ
avant
de la précarité de la pauvreté c'est
d'être propriétaire de son logement
parce que pour des personnes de classe
moyenne être propriétaire à la retraite
ça permet de pas avoir un loyer à
supporter or on ne peut pas déconnecter
la question des retraites de la question
de l'accession à la propriété et si on
veut demain assurer un pouvoir d'achat
pour les futurs retraités il faut aussi
permettre et englober la question de
l'accession à la propriété notamment de
tous ceux qui ont travaillé et qui et il
y a une vraie différence dans les
générations la génération qui a la
retraite actuellement quand elle a
travaillé souvent elle a pu accéder à la
propriété les générations actuelles qui
travaillent ont eu plus de difficultés
d'accéder à la propriété il faut qu'on
puisse s'atteler à cette question là de
manière à pouvoir assurer demain un
pouvoir d'achat à nos retraités il y a
dans ce projet la question du minimum
vieillesse avec un seuil qui est
réaugmenter par rapport à la
récupération
sur le patrimoine qui est monté à 100000
euros c'est une bonne chose mais ça ne
suffit pas parce qu'en fait ça va être
valable pour ceux qui sont actuellement
à la retraite mais comme ceux qui vont
être à la retraite demain et après
demain seront beaucoup moins
propriétaires ils ne pourront pas
bénéficier de cependant il faut pouvoir
leur permettre de bénéficier de
cependant et favoriser la propriété
merci bien la parole est à Monsieur
Vigier
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègue comme le disait d'ailleurs non
sans Mali Jérôme Guedj je suis un peu
surpris qu'on débate
la rétablissement de l'ISF au sein d'une
commission des affaires sociales dans le
cas d'un plfssr donc faut se réjouir du
fait que c'est débats puissent avoir
lieu puisque il est sur la table
allons-y que tu as recevabilité donc a
permis que nous puissions en discuter et
oui en fait c'est pas une approche
technique c'est une approche politique
cette approche politique elle s'appuie
sur le fait et chacun sait que la France
ça s'est incontestable un niveau de
prédom obligatoire qui est parmi les
plus élevés si ce n'est le premier de
tous les pays vraiment développés et
malgré cela et pourtant vous savez qu'on
a déployé des efforts et je me souviens
d'ailleurs il y a quelques années avec
un président de la république socialiste
on nous disait aussi qu'il fallait quand
même arrêter c'est pris le mobigatoire
qui provoquait une séquestration en fait
de l'investissement qu'il soit privé ou
qu'il soit public évidemment puis après
le MOB obligatoire chacun sait nos
capacités d'action en sont limité mais
surtout privées vous savez cette France
a connu une telle vague de
désinscrivation et on commence on
commence à amorcer quelque chose de
positif et c'est amorce c'est le fruit
naturellement d'une évolution de la
fiscalité la deuxième chose un collègue
de la nuit pas disait tout à l'heure
vous nous parlez de capitalisation pas
du tout c'est parce qu'on veut sauver le
système de répartition est-ce qu'il y a
un article est-ce qu'il y a quelque
chose qui fait référence à la
capitalisation non en aucun et enfin
quand on disait c'est parfaitement juste
au moins dans cette réforme il y a deux
sujets qui pour nous sont importants en
tout cas aux yeux de notre groupe
naturellement c'est ce que nous allons
faire pour les carrières hachées j'ai
pensé aux aidants je pense aux quatre
trimestres pour les congés parentaux et
il y a des sujets notamment sur la
maternité que ce soit sur la table mais
vous savez dans la réforme de 2015 je
suis surpris de voir que dans cette
réforme là vous n'avez rien fait
justement pour celles et ceux qui
doivent attendre 67 ans pour avoir une
retraite à taux plein et ce sont souvent
des femmes et bien ce sont des angles
que nous portons dans cette retraite
pour améliorer justement dans le cas des
cahiers arrachées les retraites qui
seront servis donc ne nous ressortez pas
c'était ça du DSF édifie parce que
franchement ça n'est pas le lieu ce
débat il a eu lieu il y aura lieu
peut-être l'aspect une alternance
politique mais ça ne sert à rien de
ressortir ses vieilles entières merci
députés très bien monsieur
merci présidente alors c'est intéressant
d'avoir ce débat même si on peut se
poser de l'intérêt dans le cas de la
réforme des retraites nous nous avons
avec Marine Le Pen une position
alternative nous n'avons pas applaudit
des deux mains ce cadeau fait à une
partie des plus riches qui était la
suppression de l'ISF mais nous nous
proposons un impôt sur la fortune
financière nous voulons pas pénaliser
les classes moyennes notamment ceux qui
héritent d'un bien familial ceux qui ont
des maisons qui parfois ont une
valorisation importante et serait taxé
par votre votre ISF voilà nous nous
proposons un impôt sur la fortune
financière sur la spéculation nous
souhaitons exonérer la résidence
principale les propriétaires de
monuments historiques les une partie des
biens agricoles l'idée contrairement à
vous c'est qu'on n'a pas une haine du
milliardaire à qui vous voulez même
couper le courant on n'a pas une haine
des plus riches on veut pas moins de
riches on veut moins de pauvres et on
veut que l'argent n'est plus riches
servent au pays soit réinvestis dans
l'économie réelle soit utile au pays
voilà la position que nous portons mais
je comprends votre intérêt votre
objectif c'est de se dire comment on
peut récupérer de l'argent et comment on
peut équilibrer ce système par
répartition alors je vais vous faire une
proposition qui va vous plaire j'en suis
certain je vous propose de supprimer le
minimum vieillesse pour les étrangers
parce qu'aujourd'hui en France il y a
une injustice incroyable une injustice
incroyable un français qui a travaillé
et qui a eu une carrière hachée ku qui a
travaillé mais qui n'a pas assez cotisé
roi le même minimum vieillesse qu'un
étranger qui est arrivé en France qui
arrivait en France et qui n'a pas cotisé
10 ans de titre de séjour sans même
avoir une seule fois cotisée ils auront
le même minimum vieillesse donc si vous
voulez une réforme de gestion sur la si
vous voulez récupérer de l'argent
supprimer ce minimum vieillesse pour les
étrangers pensez aux Français pour la
première fois pensez aux Français en
priorité parce que c'est eux qui nous
regardent aujourd'hui c'est eux qui
attendent qu'on défend leur retraite
très bien
monsieur Colombani
merci Madame présidente donc oui il va
falloir du financement des actifs va
baisser oui il va falloir réformer mais
pourquoi toujours les mêmes pistes et
pour voir pour pour toujours uniquement
la piste de l'âge légal notre groupe
avait déposé des amendements qui ont du
mal vu le timing à être à être examiné
mais nous avions déposé des amendements
notamment sur le financement par rapport
à la CSG patrimoine sur les dividendes
record sur le capital voilà le regret de
ce texte est qu'on aura pas les moyens
de d'examiner sereinement
c'est ce texte correctement
s'il vous plaît mes collègues ont chers
collègues on s'écoute il n'est même pas
encore 10 heures et vous êtes remonté
comme des coucou s'il vous plaît on
ouvre les chakras et on et aussi s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît alors
sur ce madame la rapporteur vous
souhaitiez non
quelqu'un c'est exprimé pour le groupe
liote monsieur Colombani s'est exprimé
alors donc monsieur monsieur de Courson
j'ai oui il s'est exprimé monsieur
Colombani donc c'est un intervenant par
groupe alors madame la rapporteur
merci merci madame
la Présidente je voudrais répondre
à la nuque déjà qui reconnaissent par
leur discussion et cette présentation
d'amendement qui a bien un déficit de
notre système de retraite dans les 25
ans je rappelle ici que votre projet
proposé de retraite
coûterait à peu près 100 milliards par
an donc si on regarde vos amendements et
qu'on veut taxer les 60 ans de proposer
par la nuque si vous voulez donc je
redis que votre projet coûte à peu près
100 milliards par an si on regarde vos
amendements présentés ici vous les taxer
donc les les grosses fortunes je
rappelle que les grosses fortunes pèsent
à peu près 500 milliards dans leur
patrimoine donc en gros vous arrivez à
financer à peu près 5 ans de votre
réforme qu'est-ce qu'on fait après bah
après on baisse les pensions que vous
aurez pas d'autre choix et donc ça
favorisera la capitalisation et sa
pénalisera les plus fragiles
très bien Madame la rapporteur général
donc je vais mettre au voie ces trois
amendements qui ont reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre
qui compte s'il vous plaît
très bien ils sont rejetés
vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente
effectivement je pense qu'on ouvre une
séquence assez décisive de notre débat
parce qu'il s'agit de parler de
financement vous nous avez expliqué que
notre système de retraite avait de
lourds problèmes de financement or en
nous pensons qu'il y a des ressources
possibles vous le choix que vous avez
fait c'est d'écarter toutes les autres
possibilités que celle de de la
longement du repos du report de l'âge
légal donc évidemment nous contestons
cette mesure qui centrale dans votre
projet et nous allons formuler un
certain nombre de propositions qui vont
dans une autre direction je voudrais
également souscrire à l'argumentaire qui
a été développé par par mon collègue
Yannick Monet il y a quelques instants
en disant qu'effectivement à force de
d'affaiblir les droits qui sont et de
dégrader les droits qui sont garantis
par le notre système par répartition on
voit bien que vous cherchez
effectivement à favoriser par ailleurs
en parallèle un système par
capitalisation d'ailleurs c'est ce que
vous avez fait avec la loi pacte il y a
pas si longtemps de cela en encourageant
d'ailleurs la capitalisation ayant
défiscalisant et en désocialisant un
certain nombre de choses donc là ce que
nous proposons c'est de réinstaurer des
taux qui nous semblent de forfait social
qui nous semblent normaux à 20% alors
qu'ils croient qu'ils étaient tombés à
16 et il me semble que c'était par le
fait de la loi pacte pour que les
systèmes par capitalisation que vous
mettez en place par ailleurs viennent
contribuer plus largement au système par
répartition et alimenter donc la
solidarité voilà la proposition qui est
celle de cet amendement que que nous
faisons et je veux évidemment ajouter
tout à l'heure madame la rapporteur vous
avez expliqué que il y avait beaucoup de
taxation sur le capital vous avez
singulièrement fait baisser ce taux
depuis 5 ou 6 ans maintenant
moi je fais pas partie de ceux qui
plaignent la finance je crois qu'on a
besoin de garantir un certain nombre de
droits et de passer des au chantage de
celles et ceux qui nous disent si c'est
comme ça on s'en va on veut garder notre
argent bon voilà si vous cédez à ce
chantage là c'est la fin de la vie
sociale et de la société et de la
solidarité à laquelle nous sommes très
attachés donc voilà tout simplement il y
a effectivement deux choix de société
qui s'affrontent ici nous avons des
propositions de financement vous vous
avez défini la sécurité sociale vous
avez écrit la confusion également y
compris en fiscalisant en remplaçant la
cotisation par de l'impôt voilà il faut
le dire nous nous proposons là ici
d'instaurer en matière de retraite un
système vertueux
très bien Madame la rapporteur votre
avis merci je crois au contraire
indispensable de continuer à favoriser
les plans d'épargne retraite dans les
entreprises parce que ça ça rapporte un
véritable gain de pouvoir d'achat pour
les salariés concernés d'ailleurs la
plupart des versements au titre des
plans d'épargne retraite sont soumis
déjà un taux forfait de forfait social
de 20%. il y a quelques exceptions près
pour le taux à 16% qui s'appliquent
qui s'applique et qui favorise
l'investissement dans les PME donc je
crois au contraire qu'il faut maintenir
ses exceptions à 16%. donc avis
défavorable
très bien monsieur Cyril Isaac Sibille
merci la présidente comme l'on indiqué
plusieurs de nos collègues on arrive sur
le sujet on est au troisième jour
des commissions on a examiné hier
aujourd'hui effectivement on voit le
problème des ressources pour financer le
système de retraite et je rappelle c'est
de retraite par répartition je voudrais
revenir sur l'excellent rapport du
commissaire au Plan quel est le souci
quel est le souci le système le système
de retraite c'est 345 milliards
de dépenses par an
le déjà actuellement ce n'est plus un
système par répartition parce que l'État
cotise au niveau des 143 milliards pour
équilibrer ces systèmes dans ces 143
milliards il y a 25 milliards qui verse
à titre d'employeurs il y a 90 milliards
qui verse au titre de compensation que
nous avons voté pour alléger les
entreprises et surtout il y a 30
milliards déjà de déficits existants et
qui pour nous sont le sujet le sujet
actuellement c'est que aujourd'hui on
est déjà sorti d'un système pas
répartition parce que l'État par les
impôts
financent une partie de ce système à
hauteur de 30 milliards et ça tous les
ans
le problème c'est d'éviter que cette
contribution de l'État n'augmente et
c'est pour ça que on fait cette réforme
pour éviter qu'à ses 30 milliards
déficites déjà compensés par l'État se
surajoute 15 milliards de divisés tous
les ans donc pour moi c'est vraiment le
sujet et l'ensemble des amendements
qu'on est amenés examinés c'est entre
guillemets comment comment sortir d'un
système par répartition en faisant en
sorte que l'État finance plus que les
recettes de l'État financent plus le
système de retraite mais si jamais le
temps finance plus le système de
retraite ça veut dire que on sort du
système par répartition et je crois sauf
le contraire qu'on est tous attachés ici
à ce système qui a été construit en 45
un sixième par répartition donc tous les
amendements qu'on va être examinés c'est
entre guillemets et qui viennent de tous
les bancs et je trouve ça intéressant
enfin de tous les bons des bandes à une
peste ils vont nous expliquer comment
sortir du système par répartition en
finançant les retraites par l'impôt
madame
merci
chers collègues moi j'attire votre
attention sur chaque pelle FSS avec
mon groupe on essaie de trouver des
solutions pour remplir les caisses et
systématiquement c'est moqueries pour ne
pas dire mépris
des idées de nous vous proposons moi je
vous rappelle quand même que en 2019 ou
2020 je ne sais plus les dates se
mélangent nous vous avions proposé par
exemple deux taxés à 100% les dividendes
sur les EHPAD privés lucratifs
oh là là ça y est c'est ça devenait pire
que tous les gauchistes quelques
semaines quelques semaines plus tard le
livre les fossoyeurs tombent oh là là
mon Dieu on pouvait pas deviner mais
qu'est-ce que c'est qui arrive c'est
tout oh ben non c'est sûr donc moi ce
que je vous dis c'est que il y a un
moment donné il va falloir écouter avec
attention aussi les propositions
de bon sens pour éviter que quelques
semaines plus tard vous vous retrouviez
encore dans une situation où vous
retrouverez le bec dans l'eau à dire oh
là là c'est vrai ils avaient raison on
pouvait pas deviner
ce que l'amendement de pierre
d'arréville est très et très bien monté
nous voterons pour
l'amendement
d'accord alors entre
vraiment entre les propos racistes et
alors poursuivez madame la députée
donc nous ce qu'on propose c'est de vous
n'arrêtez pas de nous dire que il faut
trouver des solutions pour financer les
retraites les solutions elles existent
elles vous sont proposées ce matin via
plusieurs amendements et nous vous
invitons donc à les voter si vraiment ce
qui vous inquiète le plus c'est le
financement voilà les solutions qui sont
devant vous très bien Monsieur Charles
de Courson
mes chers collègues quelques questions
sur cette amendement le grand set
affecte le produit
au régime obligatoire de base
d'assurance vieillesse mais je croyais
que nous n'avions pas le droit
d'affecter une recette fiscale à un
régiment on peut augmenter les
cotisations existantes donc est-ce que
Madame la rapporteur pourriez nous dire
est-ce que cet amendement était vraiment
recevable deuxième observation
deuxième observation
je voudrais attirer l'attention de mes
collègues que vous croyez qu'avec cet
amendement vous allez refaire payer les
grandes fortunes je vous rassure elles
ne paieront rien pourquoi parce que il y
a un plafonnement
ISF plus IR plus taxe foncière par
rapport aux revenus qui est grosso modo
à 70
75%. or vous savez ce que font les très
grandes fortunes parce que dans les 50
premières grandes fortunes aucune ne
paye l'ISF 0 et les autres payent pas
10% du barème pourquoi c'est très simple
vous faites une holding vous mettez vos
participations dans la holding et vous
ne faites pas verser dividendes à vous
même et donc vous n'avez pas de revenu
et donc grâce au plafonnement vous ne
payez plus d'ISF et pas plus d'hier
alors comment vous vivez vous allez voir
votre banquier il vous fait des prêts à
la consommation et puis de temps en
temps vous réalisez quelques actifs pour
les rembourser voilà le mécanisme donc
ne vous faites pas d'illusions c'est pas
par cet amendement que vous ferez payer
les grandes fortunes de plus si vous
pouviez nous éclairer madame le
rapporteur sur le point de la
recevabilité de cet amendement et puis
dernier point mes chers collègues si
nous sommes tous attachés à la
répartition il faut bien voir que si on
commence à mettre des impôts que ce soit
de la TVA de l'ISF de l'IR ou que
sais-je pour financer les éléments
contributs des retraites mes chers
collègues vous détruisaient le système
de répartition
oui merci madame la Présidente notre
système par répartition repose sur un
une équation assez simple finalement on
a un nombre de cotisants avec un niveau
de cotisation qui doit correspondre à un
nombre de retraités avec un niveau de
pension on ne veut ni baisser le pouvoir
d'achat des retraités ni baisser le
pouvoir d'achat des personnes qui qui
travaille actuellement des cotisants
donc il y a deux vecteurs qui sont à mon
avis beaucoup plus efficaces sur la
question de l'équilibre durable c'est le
taux d'emploi et le taux de natalité en
fait il faut qu'on ait des nouveaux
cotisants et des cotisants donc ça passe
par le travail qui finance d'une
certaine manière cette protection
sociale sur ce sur le niveau du travail
ces solutions de financement elles vont
pas impacter et et je rejoins les
arguments le vrai sujet c'est comment on
améliore le taux d'emploi de ce qui ont
un taux d'emploi faible je pense aux
jeunes je pense au Seigneur je pense au
maire de famille tout à l'heure on citer
le commissaire aux plans moi il y a une
phrase qui m'a ce matin quand il dit il
faut que les années de maternité ne
soient pas un handicap pour la retraite
mais oui parce que des mères qui
travaillent ça permet d'apporter aussi
pour notre système si les jeunes ne
croient plus en l'avenir de notre
système qui doute de l'avenir qu'ils ont
peur de la transmission d'une certaine
manière il n'accueilleront pas la vie et
en plus il travaille pas et on a besoin
d'encourager ce modèle c'est vraiment un
écueil et si on y répond dans le projet
et qu'on corrige le projet et qu'on le
complète là on répondra à la fois la
question du taux de natalité et du taux
d'emploi et ça permettra d'apporter et
des droits familiaux c'est c'est
vraiment un des gros écueils aujourd'hui
même le rapporteur je vous invite
vraiment sur ce point là de répondre à
cette question des maires de famille qui
travaillent de pouvoir faire en sorte
que le fait d'acquérir la vie leur
pouvoir d'achat ne diminue pas et quand
les valises est-ce que ça permet
d'apporter je suis pas sûr que ces taxes
qui en plus faut être très clair c'est
le travail et c'est les cotisations sur
le travail qui financent les retraites
c'est pas les éléments sur le patrimoine
qui dépendent du budget de l'État très
bien merci
madame la Présidente alors cet
amendement qui est qui en effet
mériterait d'être soutenu et
véritablement sur le fond puisque
l'épargne salariale est un des sujets
est un des leviers sur lesquels nous
pouvons financer une partie du déficit
des retraites je rappelle quand même des
chiffres qui devraient nous alerter
parce que
on fait de la politique au nom d'un bien
commun et au nom de quel bien commun
c'est les décisions que je vais vous
lister ont-elles été prises telle est la
question en fait aujourd'hui et sur donc
je vous cite les je vous cite les
exemples parce que vraiment on a un
problème à la fin de au nom de quoi nous
faisons cette politique la première
c'est la participation des entreprises
au financement de la sécurité sociale à
diminué de près de 20 points depuis 1995
depuis 1995 les entreprises ont diminué
leur participation financement de notre
système de sécurité sociale de 20 points
au nom de quoi en fait est-ce que
l'économie va beaucoup mieux aujourd'hui
qu'elle n'allait en 199 est-ce qu'en
1995 nous étions dans une situation la
pire soit et bien non en réalité ce qui
s'est produit c'est qu'il y a eu un
enrichissement des plus riches l'aide
aux entreprises les aides aux
entreprises ont progressé les aides aux
entreprises ont progressé de
1470% de
1470% en 40 ans les aides aux
entreprises on est vraiment ont augmenté
de
1470% mais de quel autre secteur
accepterions-nous une telle augmentation
les entreprises sont sous perfusion
d'argent public et vous pensez que c'est
ça qui fait que l'économie va bien mais
non la réalité c'est que les entreprises
devraient pouvoir s'en sortir sans avoir
157 milliards d'aide aux entreprises les
plus riches n'est 1% les plus riches ont
capté 63% de la richesse créée au niveau
national depuis le covid au nom de quoi
faisons-nous de la politique au nom de
quel bien commun telle est la question
qui est posée aujourd'hui
monsieur dareville vous avez la parole
on évite de s'applaudir s'il vous plaît
merci madame la Présidente
tout à l'heure lorsque Madame la
rapporteur employé l'expression de taxer
le capital expression que pour ce qui
nous concerne nous assumons elle a
finalement mis en lumière une réalité
c'est qu'il y a effectivement un choix
très simple très binaire c'est soit on
s'occupe du capital soit on s'occupe du
travail Vous vous avez choisi de faire
casquer les salariés dans cette dans
cette histoire là et de le faire très
fort d'un côté comme vient de le dire
Sandrine Rousseau juste raison on
distribue les milliards et de l'autre on
vole des années de retraite aux salariés
donc ça c'est la première chose qu'il
faut quand même préciser la deuxième la
cotisation qui pour nous est le socle du
financement de la protection sociale et
Thibault Bazin disait il y a quelques
instants que c'est la cotisation sur le
travail qui doit primer qui doit compter
contact mais alors il faut arrêter la
foire aux exonérations de cotisations la
foire aux exonérations chaque année pour
le PLFSS c'est insupportable et il faut
arrêter aussi le contournement du
salaire avec les primes Macron
d'ailleurs c'est pas lui les distribue
et je ne sais quoi encore qui ne
financent pas notre système de retraite
de protection sociale vous avez tout
fait pour contourner le salaire pour
contourner le financement de retraite et
maintenant vous expliquer qu'il y a un
trou dans la caisse c'est les Daltons
qui crient au voleur cette histoire là
donc à un moment donné où ça suffit et
effectivement il y en a marre de cette
politique là donc lorsque Monsieur Isaac
Sibille nous explique que lui il défend
le système par répartition épanou
franchement si c'était pas triste ça me
donnerait envie de rigoler nous
défendons le système par répartition
bien sûr c'est ça que nous défendons et
la difficulté c'est que vous vous avez
accrédité un autre système parallèle qui
est le système par capitalisation et un
certain nombre de gens aujourd'hui se
disent si je veux avoir une bonne
retraite il faut aussi que je mette de
côté voilà en abaissant les droits c'est
ça que vous produisez donc là ce que
nous proposons tout simplement à travers
cet amendement c'est de répondre à la
question où est la priorité vous nous
expliquez il y a un gros problème de
financement de nos de notre système par
répartition où est la priorité c'est là
la priorité alors on y va et on veut de
cet amendement monsieur de la porte
monsieur de la porte merci madame la
Présidente
moi je souhaiterais simplement revenir
sur ce dont on parle actuellement madame
Rousseau évoqué à juste titre les 150
milliards d'aide aux entreprises chaque
année ça a l'air de choquer personne et
inversement monsieur Isa Sybille nous
dit
bon on a 30 milliards d'euros qui sont
de déficits qui sont compensés par les
tâches chaque année alors 30 milliards
d'euros ça vous choque d'un côté sauf
qu'en fait c'est même pas 30 milliards
d'euros parce que quand vous dit 30
milliards d'euros c'est finalement ça
prend en compte les cotisations de
l'État employeur c'est une des vieilles
lui vies de la droite et d'ailleurs pour
citer le rapport du corps il dit que
même quand les régimes sont placés sur
un pied d'égalité avec une même assiette
de cotisation à même ratio démographique
les taux pratiqués dans le public et
dans le privé sont équivalents ça c'est
ce que dit le corps il dit aussi le
corps en outre réduire les dépenses de
retraite de l'État n'est ni possible ni
souhaitable parce que les niveaux de
taux de remplacement ou d'âge de la
retraite des fonctionnaires de l'État
serait alors en décalage important avec
celui du reste de la population
et fini de lire le corps une telle
approche n'est ni appropriée parce
qu'elle stigmatise indument la
générosité du régime du la fonction
publique et mon camarade Vigier
convenait tout à l'heure qui n'était pas
si généreux que ça
ni opératoire parce qu'elle ne peut
servir de guide à une politique publique
donc vous voyez d'un côté vous dites bon
on a un déficit qui n'est pas justifié
et qui n'est pas exact dans les 30
milliards que vous dénoncez et puis de
l'autre vous refusez de venir avec nous
pour dire on a 150 milliards et mettons
qu'on revienne pas en arrière sur ces
147 ou 150 milliards d'euros
d'exonération on sait pas ce qu'on vous
demande mais on vous demande d'arrêter
de dire il y a 30 milliards d'euros qui
sont compensés par l'État parce que ce
n'est pas vrai c'est des cotisations qui
sont aussi versées par l'État donc voilà
il faut rétablir et remettre la mairie
au milieu du village
très bien Madame Prisca Thévenot
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues voilà
maintenant deux jours que nous sommes
réunis ensemble et une chose est sûre à
chaque problème une solution et en
l'occurrence à chaque problème un impôt
du de la part de nos collègues de gauche
si c'est pas un impôt supplémentaire
c'est une augmentation une augmentation
de cotisation si c'est pas une
augmentation de cotisations c'est taper
celles et ceux qui réussissent en gros
planter des planter des députés de
nuppes à l'Assemblée nationale il en
poussera des impôts pour les Français au
nom de quoi au nom du principe qu'il
n'existerait pas de politique de
redistribution en France mes chers
collègues notre pays bénéficie dans déjà
d'une politique de redistribution socio
fiscale qui réduit les inégalités selon
l'Insee la redistribution fait passer
les écarts de revenus de 1 à 13 s'il
vous plaît
dit les fameux 10% les plus riches
madame Rousseau et les plus modestes
dit autrement on divise par 4 les
inégalités avec notre système de
prestation sociale de fiscalité et nos
services publics alors taxer plus ce
n'est pas pour mieux redistribuer c'est
pour mieux taper vous hurlez en
permanence contre le rassemblement
national mais où vous employez les mêmes
méthodes le mépris pour seul boussole
alors j'aime bien que vous vous
inspiriez de Walt Disney et des Robins
des bois pour pour faire vos actions
excusez-moi ça fait sourire nos enfants
mais c'est très dangereux pour nos aînés
très bien
très bien alors avant de prendre s'il
vous plaît je donne la parole à Madame
la rapporteur général avant de voter
merci madame la Présidente d'abord pour
répondre à monsieur de Courson tous les
tous les ans dans le cadre du pffss nous
avons des amendements qui affectent des
ressources aux branches les dernières
étaient on en avait beaucoup par exemple
dans le péripéths 2023 sur la branche
autonomie et je vous renvoie l'article
LO
111-3-4 qui définit la partie recette
des lois de financement et qui prévoit
que les recettes peuvent être affectées
aux branches pour répondre à Madame
Rousseau vous dites que nous faisons des
cadeaux aux entreprises mais aujourd'hui
est présenté par le ministre Gabriel
Attal le bilan des rentrées fiscales
2022 et il est montré que le rendement
de l'impôt sur la société est en
amélioration de 3 milliards
on est à l'heure actuelle avec le
montant le plus élevé de l'histoire
alors qu'on a le taux d'imposition le
plus bas de l'histoire donc il y a les
mots et il y a l'effet enfin pour
répondre à Monsieur
vous dites que c'est la foire aux
exonérations mais dans ce cadre et dans
le cas de cet amendement ces
exonérations bénéficient d'abord aux
gens qui ont les plus petits salaires
donc il me semble important d'être de
rester défavorable à cet amendement
très bien donc je mets aux voix cet
amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur qui
est pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté
amendement suivant madame châtelain
merci madame la Présidente en préalable
je note qu'il faut définitivement
renoncer à l'adage la nuit porte conseil
parce que j'espérais que vous auriez à
la faveur de quelques heures de sommeil
mesurait l'ampleur historique de ce qui
s'est passé hier 2,8 millions de
personnes dans la rue 8700 personnes à
Annonay dans la ville du ministre du
soft ce qui veut dire que plus vous
faites de la pédagogie plus les gens
comprennent et plus les gens comprennent
plus ils rejettent ils rejettent votre
votre réforme alors cette amendement
propose de remettre à niveau la
contribution sociale généralisée sur les
paris et jeux de hasard en augmentant
les taux et assurant aux besoins
l'affectation au risque vieillesse et
ses institutions pour les nouvelles
sommes supplémentaires dégagées
je veux vous dire si je peux si Monsieur
vigime laisse terminer qu'en réalité
votre votre laxisme fiscal c'est ce
qu'on essaye de vous expliquer depuis
tout à l'heure votre laxisme fiscal à
altérer nos finances publiques de
cadeaux fiscaux en exonération sans
contrepartie et c'est cela aussi que
nous voulons corriger c'est ce laxisme
que nous voulons corriger nous nous
opposons vous l'avez compris à la
politique de rabot d'allongement de la
durée de travail comme prétendu mode de
financement de notre système de retraite
que vous voulez imposer à proposer
imposer à un pays qui est unanimement
unanimement on l'a vu hier et toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion le démontre hostile
très bien monsieur Erica lozet
merci madame la Présidente vous
souhaitez augmenter le taux de CSG sur
les sur les jeux hors celle-ci la porte
déjà presque 500 millions d'euros par an
à la sécurité sociale avec une assiette
qui est très dynamique puisqu'elle
apporterait 300 elle apportait 390
millions en 2020 donc il ne faut pas
diminuer ce dynamisme et donc c'est un
avis défavorable
très bien monsieur alosé oui merci
madame la Présidente alors chers
collègues de la nupaise vous nous
promettez dégrainer ce matin toutes vos
pistes de financement qui d'ailleurs ne
feront avancer aucunement le débat sur
l'équilibre des régimes de retraite mais
tant mieux tant mieux après tout parce
que c'est l'heure de vérité d'une
certaine façon et cela va nous permettre
de montrer l'inefficacité de vos
propositions modulo le fait que vous
mélangez en plus le budget de l'État
avec celui de des retraites et
prestations sociales ce qui est
totalement
aberrant mais enfin bon admettons
allons-y donc premier mérite premier
mérite déjà c'est que vous reconnaissez
qu'il y a un déficit c'est quand même
important j'espère que vous le dites
dans les manifestations vous allez
continuer à dire aux gens qui a pas de
déficit si vous vous reconnaissez
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs vu les milliards
que vous mobilisez dans un moment c'est
vraiment une reconnaissance patente des
déficites donc la nups reconnaît
officiellement aujourd'hui en commission
des affaires sociales l'existence d'un
déficit sur le régime de retraite merci
pour cette aveu et cette reconnaissance
enfin un peu de sérieux c'est une bonne
chose effectivement alors vous
reconnaissez le déficit donc 13
milliards 5 c'est bien l'enjeu de notre
de notre projet 13005 + 6 milliards pour
apporter de un peu plus de justice et de
progrès dans le régime 13 milliards 5
bon je reviens pas sur les 30 milliards
donc c'est très fort n'est pas ni utile
ni non urgente et l'être utile et elle
est urgente alors urgente pas en dizaine
de milliards demain c'est pour ça que
nous la commençons progressivement en
2000 pour la génération 61 et puis 62
etc c'est progressif parce que
l'accumulation des déficits fera que
dans 5 ans on se retournera vers les
législateurs et leur dire à m'attendait
là on a déjà 50 milliards mais qu'est-ce
que vous avez foutu qu'est-ce que vous
avez foutu dans l'hémicycle voilà donc
il faut commencer progressivement parce
que à terme ce sont des déficits
importants et puis
vous savez je crois que avec vos
propositions au fond vous sapés vous
sapez le régime de répartition vous
saper les principes du CNR ou principe
vous saper les principes de ce que dans
une grande communauté de destin et le
Parti communiste historique et les
communistes historiques et général de
Gaulle ont tenté de faire pour
progresser notre pays
merci madame la Présidente je vous
propose de laisser Jaurès Blum moulin
d'autres de côté parce que là on en est
pas loin donc alors juste pour dire à
Madame la rapporteur qui disait tout à
l'heure que l'impôt sur les sociétés sur
les sociétés d'ailleurs parce que la
société ça n'existe pas mais l'impôt sur
les sociétés avait augmenté de 3
milliards d'euros alors même que vous
aviez baissé les taux ça c'est je
voudrais quand même le mettre en regard
de la baisse de CVAE qui a été votée par
enfin non qui n'a pas été voté puisque
c'est un 49-3 qui a été décidé par le
gouvernement et qui va représenter un
manque à gagner de 8 milliards donc en
fait ce que vous faites c'est que mal
les 1470% d'augmentation des aides aux
entreprises depuis 40 ans vous continuez
à diminuer les impôts sur les
entreprises par ailleurs votre référence
votre référence sur baisser les taux
d'imposition pour augmenter les recettes
c'est la courbe de la ferme la courbe de
la ferme c'est le principe c'est trop
d'impôts tue l'impôt c'est quand même
une courbe qui a été c'est quand même
une courbe qui a été
balayée par toutes les analyses
économiques depuis Ronald Reagan depuis
Ronald Reagan et franchement si c'est
pour un retour origan vraiment ça ne
vaut pas le coup
très bien monsieur alors j'ai deux
demandes monsieur dit Philippot monsieur
viri c'est Monsieur Viry ou monsieur dit
Philippot non mais justement je vous
mets de vous mettre d'accord
je vous laisse vous mettre d'accord
monsieur dit Philippot allez-y je
commence madame la Présidente et sur
l'amendement suivant vous pouvez danser
déjà je pense inscrire monsieur viri qui
complétera
utilement notre réflexion je voulais
quand même signaler à ce stade
effectivement une double hypocrisie mais
qui est partagée aussi bien par la
gauche macroniste que par la gauche
nuque sur ce sujet là on avait dénoncé
et à l'époque la nuque également
l'hypocrisie dans les débats budgétaires
qui consistait dès qu'il y avait un
problème à vouloir créer un loto
notamment le loto du patrimoine qui
devait régler le problème de l'entretien
du patrimoine dans notre dans notre pays
aujourd'hui et bien on revient un peu
sur le même principe augmenter les taxes
sur les sur les jeux de de hasard et
l'autre partie de cette hypocrisie et
bien c'est pour la majorité qui
elle-même a augmenté la CSG manière
jamais vue et j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure dans un autre amendement et de
dire que là et bien les problématiques
d'augmenter
cet axe là alors ces contradictions
entre ces deux visages de la gauche sont
encore loin d'être résolus mais en tout
état de en tout état de cause on a eu le
loto du patrimoine on a vu que ça n'a
pas réglé le problème c'est pas parce
que demain on augmente les taxes sur les
jeux où on crée une forme peut-être ça
ouvre la porte à un loto des retraites
ou un loto des EHPAD que ce problème là
sera résolu donc bien entendu de ce côté
si de la salle je pense avec les
collègues nous n'approuvrons absolument
pas ce principe et ses propositions très
bien monsieur turquois
merci madame la Présidente d'abord je
voudrais avoir une pensée pour les
centaines de milliers d'entrepreneurs
qui écoutent les propos de Madame
Rousseau je voudrais simplement madame
Roussos un moment donné je sais pas si
dans votre vie que vous créez votre
entreprise ou vous essayez d'en
reprendre une petite PME et voir quelle
est l'écart qu'il y a entre les propos
que vous tenez et la réalité de ce qui
est vécu donc je vous invite vraiment à
le faire parce que il y a une création
de richesse qui a assuré qui assuré par
eux parce que il y a un système éducatif
de qualité en France parce qu'il y a un
système de protection sociale en France
mais ils contribuent pleinement et les
propos que vous tenez sont
particulièrement blessants à leur égard
ensuite le système des retraites je
parle pas de la sécurité sociale je
parle du système des retraites
et souvent les communistes nous l'ont
rappelés par l'intermédiaire d'Ambroise
Croizat il est clairement indiqué que
c'est un système par répartition les
salariés d'aujourd'hui cotisent et
assure la pension des retraités
d'aujourd'hui et donc si on fiscalise
les recettes de de du système de
retraite alors on sera plus dans un
système par répartition c'est un
changement fondamental et en termes de
solidarité des générations ça a une
incidence très forte prés je vais on va
profiter parce que comme vous faites de
l'obstruction mais on va vous répondre à
tous les points et on va montrer
progressivement la vanité de ce que ce
que vous montrez par exemple vous
expliquer vous expliquer que
on a largement vidé le système alors
tout ce qui est réduction de charges et
compensée et tout ce qui est
l'équivalent de la prime Macron par
exemple qui a souvent été cité mais la
prime Macron c'est une prime de pouvoir
d'achat donc certes il y a pas de
cotisation dessus mais elle ne donne pas
de droit non plus c'est uniquement du
pouvoir d'achat donc mesurer ça évaluer
avant de sortir je ne sais quelle je ne
sais quel contre vérité et donc nous
nous sommes pour un système par
répartition on peut l’alimenter comment
par les cotisations d'aujourd'hui donc
en améliorant comme la dit notre
collègue Bazin le taux d'emploi le taux
d'emploi des plus jeunes le taux
d'emploi des seniors et on voit que
quand on améliore le taux d'emploi comme
l'année dernière et bien il peut y avoir
un excédent et c'est pour ça que nous
proposons une clause de revoyure en 2027
pour voir en fonction de la situation
monsieur d'arriville
merci merci madame la Présidente
je voudrais commencer par rappeler que
si nous devons discuter de ces sujets et
je crois que c'est important de le faire
c'est aussi parce que le PLFSS
n'a pas été adopté par notre assemblée
en tout cas par défaut à cause du 49-3
et il a pas été non plus discuté en
vérité comme il aurait dû l'être donc
essayons d'avoir cette discussion elle
est elle est nécessaire et je regrette
que dans cet échange certains se prêtent
à des jeux de confusion qui me semblent
finalement assez contre-productif pour
eux-mêmes
lorsque on parle de la distinction entre
la cotisation sociale et l'impôt moi
j'en suis effectivement le premier
défenseur de cette distinction sauf que
l'étatisation de la protection sociale a
été menée à marche forcée depuis la fin
des années 90 sauf que dans le champ
lexical qui est le vôtre vous mélangez
tout vous-même puisque vous nous parlez
de prélèvement obligatoire et de charge
là où il y a des cotisations sociales
des cotisations points sociales des
employeurs il y a de l'impôt d'autre
part qui ne servent pas à financer la
même chose mais vous vous mélangez tout
vous mélangez tout vous faites exprès
quand ça vous arrange évidemment voilà
donc je crois qu'il faut effectivement
restaurer un petit peu de clarté dans
cette discussion et éviter la confusion
et ensuite il y a une confusion
politique que vous essayez d'entretenir
j'en ai entendu certains d'entre vous se
revendiquaient qui de croisades Jaurès
etc alors moi je suis très heureux qu'on
parle dans brasse croisable c'est un
personnage qui a été beaucoup laissé de
côté dans l'histoire mais je voudrais
pas quand même que
finalement on l'insulte en se
revendiquant de lui voilà donc je le dis
de manière très calme et très
sympathique mais en réalité avec un peu
de colère et lorsque dans le débat
précédent que nous avions eu certains
ici sans rappel vous aviez prétendu déjà
il y a deux ans de faire la
démonstration de je ne sais quoi en
réalité la seule démonstration qui a été
faite c'est que le projet ne tournait
pas il a été abandonné
certains avaient déjà tenté cette
opération là et je je leur avais dit là
aussi très calmement je crois qu'en ce
revendiquant les héritiers du CNR de
Ambroise croizan en cassant cet héritage
il n'en était pas les exécuteurs
testamentaires mais les exécuteurs tout
court
très bien la parole est à Madame La
Valette madame la Présidente merci nous
de voterons pas cette amendement une
taxe supplémentaire pas très étonnée de
la part de la nuit pêche mais puisqu'on
est en train de parler de la CSG je vous
rappelle que la CSG finance l'assurance
maladie les retraites et les prestations
sociales et figurez-vous que si nous
réservions les prestations sociales aux
Français ou alors aux étrangers ayant
pouvant justifier de 5 ans
d'équivalentes en plein alors
figurez-vous mes chers collègues de la
nuit parce que toutes ces économies qui
seraient faites dans cette branche de
prestation sociale pourrait être
évidemment réfléchi vers les retraites
donc vous voyez mes collègues aussi de
la majorité des recettes on peut en
trouver et c'est simplement que votre
programme il est il est petit bras en
fait c'est c'est le programme de la
loose c'est de penser que jamais on
réindustrialisera le pays c'est de
penser que des économies il y en a pas
et du coup ce sont encore les Français
qui vont payer de façon injustes les
mauvais choix politiques que vous faites
notamment en matière de prestation
sociale je vous remercie
très bien la parole est à Monsieur Guedj
excusez-moi madame la Présidente cet
amendement
allez-y prenez le micro
on est sur l'amendement 7221 sur lequel
vous vous êtes inscrit non mais si vous
ne voulez pas nous
d'accord très bien Monsieur Paul
Christophe
oui merci c'était simplement un petit
intervention pour assurer pierre
Daredevil c'est juste ça tellement pas
voilà de mettre en défaut embrasse
croisade simplement rappeler aussi qu'il
était
soutenu par une administration et rendre
hommage aussi à Pierre Laroque peut-être
au passage qu'il a accompagné mais aussi
dire que à l'époque lorsque le
dispositif a répartition a été imaginé
il était équilibré voyez-vous il était
équilibré jamais il le serait venu et
bien à ceux qui sortait du CNR de
proposer un déficit tel qu'on le vit
aujourd'hui et il reposait donc sur un
financement oui un financement par
cotisation à la fois salariale et
patronale
très bien mes chers collègues tout le
monde s'est exprimé sur cette amendement
madame la rapporteur et après on passe
au vote s'il vous plaît
oui je voudrais répondre à Madame
Rousseau pour redire que les recettes
parce que j'ai peut-être pas été clair
avant dans ma prise de parole mais les
recettes des impôts sur les sociétés
atteignent un record à 62 milliards
d'euros en 2022 preuve que quand on
baisse l'impôt sur les sociétés on
récolte plus d'impôts sur la CVAE ça va
d'ailleurs plaire à Madame La Valette
effectivement cette exonération va
permettre d'augmenter l'emploi notamment
dans l'industrie et donc là aussi
d'amener des recettes et notamment des
recettes sociales
très bien donc je mets aux voix cet
amendement 7221 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur qui
est pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté amendement
identique alors qui le défend le 33 37
du côté de la nuit de pêche enfin de la
France insoumise plus exactement
madame kéké
ah très bien mais vous défendez alors
Monsieur cloué le 33 37
d'accord ok d'accord alors qui prend la
parole
d'accord alors madame érody 38 allez-y
merci madame la Présidente collègue je
vais tenter une période manœuvre je vais
essayer de me mettre à votre place vous
voulez combler un pseudo difficile ce
n'est ni nécessaire ni juste mais
admettons vous cherchez donc 12
milliards et avec cette réforme vous
voulez faire payer aux Français les
cadeaux que vous avez fait au très
grandes entreprises et qui n'ont eu
aucun impact sur l'emploi je vous
rappelle que revenir sur la suppression
de le CVAE c'est 8 milliards de gains et
que réinstorelli SF c'est 3 milliards ce
qui fait déjà un milliards vous ne
voulez pas entendre raison endettons les
niches fiscales le plus injustes comme
les niches sociales et fiscales de la
capitalisation dans la suppression
rapporterait de milliards en impôt sur
le revenu et 3,4 milliards votre système
de retraite à court terme il ne faut pas
y toucher admettons
vous refusez par ailleurs de faire
contribuer les plus riches les
ultra-riches ce qui serait aussi une
solution pour dégager une marge mais
pour vous c'est à bout admettons bref
retirons pas paresse intellectuelle et
avec le Main idéologique toutes ces
possibilités que nous reste-t-il il nous
reste le fond de réserve sur les
retraites de la Cadès que l'on pourrait
affecter au financement des systèmes de
retraite la dette sociale l'étape la
reprendre et la faire rouler en ne
payant que les intérêts ce qui
permettrait de rapporter 19 milliards
oui 19 milliards et si l'on décide de
ralentir seulement se remboursement en
affectant la CRDS uniquement alors ces
10 milliards qui financent à court terme
nos retraites quand on dit qu'au rythme
actuel la cadence n'aura plus de dettes
à rembourser en 2033 il serait
complètement ridicule démagogique de ne
pas de ne pas mobiliser ses ressources
allez collègues marcheurs RN et alliés
sortent un peu de votre aveugle
aveuglement idéologique car ce sont les
citoyens et les citoyens qui paieraient
les pots cassés le RN s'il vous plaît
pouvez être un peu
respectueux et ne pas mépriser quand il
y en a qui parlent merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup les vilains méchants vous avez
la parole
monsieur Clouet vous avez la parole
merci s'il vous plaît
un petit peu à droite parce qu'on est
bien compris qu'il voulait exemple tes
dIESEL Montre tout mais si on pouvait
aussi avoir un peu de silence ça serait
agréable alors sur sur les questions qui
sont posées depuis une heure juste un
point de retour d'abord on rappellera
que le CNR puisqu'il a beaucoup été
invoqué prévoyant 43 un financement par
l'état des Caisses d'Assurance
Vieillesse donc sans réclamer et
totalement faux puisque c'est en 45
seulement qu'on met en place le système
des cotisations et on le fait en portant
la part patronale de 4 à 10% des
salaires et la part salariés de 4 à 6
donc si vous voulez vous inspirer du CNR
c'est simple c'est plus 50% de taux de
cotisation avec les salaires qui suivent
j'ai envie de vous dire chiche désormais
maintenant sur la question de
l'amendement dont nous parlons vous le
savez avant 96 avant qu'on crée la
cadèse donc cette grande tirelire qui
est censée saisir et récupérer une
partie des titres de dettes de la
sécurité sociale les comptes de la
Sécurité sociale elle-même étaient soit
excédentaires soit à l'équilibre et en
cas de déséquilibre l'état compensé par
pas de dotation la Cadès c'est la fin de
ses compensations ça nous pose
évidemment un problème cette cadette est
une filiale de l'État là aussi vous le
savez qui devait disparaître nous a
promis sa disparition en 2009 puis en
2014 puis en 2021 puis désormais en 2025
je crains qu'en 2050 les gens qui
siègeront ici soit encore en train d'en
discuter la disparition future bref on
n'arrive pas à s'en débarrasser ce qui
est un problème non seulement pour le
sens qu'elle a mais aussi pour les
pratiques qu'elle suscite puisque la
CADES est quand même un organisme qui
est habilité à spéculer sur des monnaies
étrangères et des marchés à terme ce qui
est un problème en termes de modalité de
financement et d'absorption de la
soi-disant dette de la sécurité sociale
je dis soit disant car il n'y a pas de
dette due par les salariés il y a un
manque de financement volontairement
orchestré de la sécurité sociale et ce à
partir d'une valeur celle du travail que
nous avons toutes et tous collectivement
créé qui est récupérée extorquer par des
réformes favorables patronales depuis 40
ans mais l'avantage de la CADES c'est
qu'elle montre qu'on peut absorber 270
milliards sans vous tirer des larmes le
sang sur les déficit insupportable
visiblement on trouve un endroit et on
propose de ralentir son remboursement
pour libérer 10 milliards d'euros
par rapport par rapport à ce débat par
rapport aux amendements
non
mais en fait vous êtes jamais content
quand l'État compense quand l'État qu'on
pense vous dites que ça va pas parce que
ça va créer un déficit pour les services
publics quand on un système est créé
notamment la CADES pour rembourser la
dette sociale ça vous convient pas non
plus nous avons demandé à la cadèse de
réaliser des nouvelles reprises de
dettes depuis 2011 en raison d'un fort
endettement du système de protection
sociale et pour faire en sorte que cette
reprise de dette soit soutenable nous
avons également décidé de affecter des
ressources nouvelles depuis la loi
organique de 2010 il s'agissait
notamment d'un versement annuel de fonds
de réserves des retraites ainsi se font
de réserve doit verser chaque année 2,1
milliards à verser 2,1 milliard sur la
période de 2011 jusqu'à 2024 vous
proposer de réaffecter ce versement la
branchevée vieillesse alors ça va
déstabiliser le financement de la Cadès
dont nous avons pourtant besoin et en
plus ça ne suffirait pas à résorber les
déficits du système de retraite donc en
fait on serait tous perdants enfin
perdant sur tous les points donc avis
défavorable
très bien et donc cette fois-ci je passe
la parole à me suivre bien effectivement
merci Madame la présente bon on parle
beaucoup de du CNR on parle beaucoup de
en tant que un des gaullistes sociales
me semble-t-il de cette assemblée je
pense qu'il faut aussi s'adapter on est
en 2023 et la question c'est de savoir
comment on finance notre protection
sociale et notamment la question des
retraites dès lors qu'on admet dès lors
qu'on admet que c'est un dossier à la
question du travail et le véritable
sujet c'est effectivement de regarder
comment notre société française est
capable à partir du travail à partir des
bulletins de salaire de générer de la
cotisation dont on a besoin et le
travail c'est forcément l'entreprise
c'est l'entreprise qui fait l'économie
c'est l'entrepreneur qui crée les
valeurs c'est l'entreprise qui fait le
social donc effectivement on n'aura pas
l'exigence de regarder la situation du
monde en 2023 elle a compétitivité de
notre économie et donc peut-être des
choix politiques à faire pour faire en
sorte qu'on puisse créer des emplois
qu'on puisse être compétitif à l'égard
de nos concurrents on écartera
effectivement le débat et on
s'accrochera à mon avis à des vieilles
lunes moi effectivement madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues je pense
qu'il lui était nécessaire voire même
opportun après 3 jours de débat que la
France interroge par rapport à ce modèle
économique et social par rapport à la
valeur du travail avant de mettre le
sujet des retraites auront au rang de
l'actualité politique parce qu'on nous
met les uns les autres dans une impasse
maintenant que nous en sommes là
peut-être faudrait-il effectivement
admettre que la France doit plus
travailler et peut-être que faudrait-il
admettre que le travail c'est peut-être
en donner plus à certains donc augmenter
le taux d'emploi ou peut-être ça peut
arrêter également mieux travailler
il ne faudrait-il pas évoquer la
question de revenir sur les 35 heures
parce que peut-être que des Français
accepteraient de travailler deux heures
de plus par semaine pour éviter de
donner deux ans de plus à la fin de leur
carrière professionnelle donc tout ça
c'est des bas ce sont des débats qu'on
peut pas avoir parce qu'un certain
nombre d'amendements sont non recevables
mais de grâce admettons la France telle
qu'elle est en 2023 et arrêtons de nous
poser et c'est à gaulliste qui vous le
dit à ce qui était la réalité de la
France en 1949
non vous avez changé
non non mais je m'adresse à Monsieur
Coulomme non
ah le gars monsieur le gars
alors j'ai également quelqu'un qui a
demandé madame Leduc alors oui ben
madame Leduc oui merci madame la
Présidente je viens en défense de ces
trois amendements vous cherchez soit
disant des moyens d'équilibrer le
système de retraite et à chaque fois
qu'on en propose un il ne trouve pas
grâce à vos yeux ce niveau d'hypocrisie
a de quoi quand même nous laisser sans
voix avec ses amendements nous cherchons
à mettre fin à une absurdité néolibérale
sortie du fin fond des années 90 la
cadette et l'instrument de la soumission
de notre système de protection sociale à
une logique marchande et financarisée en
effet avec la création de la Cadès en 96
les gouvernements successifs ont imposés
à la sécurité sociale de passer par les
marchés financiers pour refinancer sa
dette deux solutions alternatives
existaient pourtant il avait fait leur
preuve de 1946 à 1996 la hausse des taux
de cotisations ou l'emprunt auprès de la
Caisse des dépôts est consignations ce
gouvernement a d'ailleurs continué dans
cette voie absurde en faisant reprendre
par la Cadès 92 milliards d'euros de
dettes covid entre 2020 et 2023 or la
cadette a toujours emprunté à des taux
d'intérêt supérieurs à ce l'état de plus
une dette prise en charge par la cadette
suppose le remboursement des intérêts du
principal alors qu'elle est à lui peut
faire rouler sa dette et ne rembourse
jamais le principal en passant par la
cadette ce sont des milliards d'euros
d'argent public issus des cotisations
des travailleurs et des travailleurs qui
sont gaspillés sur les marchés
financiers et après cela ce gouvernement
et sa minorité parlementaire va nous
donner des leçons de responsabilité
budgétaire permettez-moi de vous dire
que les montages fumeux de type cadet
montre bien que les désirs responsables
c'est vous l'économiste Ana Carolina
cordilla a estimé le coût de la
financiarisation de la dette de la
sécurité sociale via la Cadès à plus de
60 milliards d'euros entre 96 et 2018
soit avant la pandémie bref avec la
cadèse les cotisations des travailleuses
et des travailleurs servent à engraisser
des rentiers le gouvernement peut alors
se lamenter sur le déficit du régime de
retraite alors qu'il a lui-même créé ce
déficit artificiel via la Cadès
donc s'il est à reprenait la dette à son
compte et que les cotisations sociales
des travailleurs arrêtés d'alimenter la
cadette cela représenterait des
milliards d'économies et vous savez que
la reprise de la dette par l'État ne
pose pas de problème d'équilibre
budgétaire puisque la dette sociale est
prise en compte dans la dette publique
au niveau européen cette opération est
donc neutre pour les finances publiques
en revanche elle représente une bouffée
d'oxygène énorme pour les régimes de
retraite que vous condamnez à la fixie
avec vos gadgets comptables comme la
Cadès les cotisations retraite doivent
servir à financer les retraites pas à
arroser des marchés financiers d'argent
public c'est pourquoi le fond de réserve
des retraites doit cesser de contribuer
à la Cadès et être redéployé vers son
objectif premier merci bien Madame la
Députée madame taillée paulian
merci madame la Présidente d'abord je
voudrais revenir sur un débat qui a eu
lieu et qui et qui nous accuserait nous
ferait le procès de vouloir
capitalisation et non pas le maintien du
du système par répartition c'est je veux
dire c'est quand même complètement
fantaisiste voir farfelu pourquoi parce
que quand nous proposons la
fiscalisation d'un certain nombre de de
recettes ce n'est pas pour remplacer les
cotisations les cotisations doivent
payer les retraites mais il y a des
inégalités profondes dans notre société
qui ne sont pas uniquement liées au
travail notamment l'inégalité entre les
femmes et les hommes et ça on peut tout
à fait imaginer on peut tout à fait
proposer que ce soit la solidarité
nationale via l'impôt qui viennent
réparer qui viennent rectifier ces
inégalités là donc on a bien le socle de
cotisations qui viennent financer les
pensions et on peut avoir un apport de
de la fiscalité pour réparer des
inégalités plus larges qui sont liées au
fonctionnement de la société sur la
question de la Cadès nous avions nous
avions à l'occasion de votre volonté de
faire porter par la cadette la dette
covid dénoncer à l'époque cette cette
proposition unique qui visait finalement
à inoculer un virus à la sécurité
sociale pour justifier plus tard des
baisses de droit c'est à dire à faire
peser sur la sécurité sociale un certain
nombre de dépenses liées au covid qui
n'avait rien à voir avec elle en disant
comme ça plus tard vous allez justifier
le fait de dire ah oui mais alors on a
des difficultés il faut rembourser etc
etc donc ce que nous vous proposons là
est donc nous soutenons les amendements
de nos collègues c'est évidemment de
remédier à cela et de faire en sorte que
l'État puisse reprendre la dette covid
l'affaire rouler ce qui nous coûtera
beaucoup moins cher et ce qui garantira
que les cotisations qui servent
actuellement à la Cadès puissent aller
et retourner alors juste place
c'est-à-dire au financement de notre
système des retraites
très bien Madame Vidal merci madame la
Présidente permettez-moi d'apporter
quelques précisions sur ces questions de
Calais et de dettes sociales si nous
avons aujourd'hui une dette sociale sur
la sécurité sociale c'est bien parce que
cette même sécurité sociale a joué
pleinement son rôle pendant la crise
sanitaire cette dette elle est
constituée à la fois des dépenses liées
à la gestion de la crise sanitaire en
termes de santé mais aussi de perte de
recettes par moindre recettes fiscales
et sociales et je préciserai que la
France a permis pendant la crise
sanitaire de soutenir ces salariés comme
aucun pays d'Europe donc oui nous avons
aujourd'hui une aide sociale alors que
avant la crise sanitaire nous étions
dans une trajectoire d'extinction de
cette dette sociale
issue je le précise principalement de la
crise de 2008 qui avait enregistré un
déficit de la Sécurité sociale jamais
connu
cela étant dit je voudrais préciser que
la Cadès n'est pas une filiale de l'État
c'est une caisse d'amortissement de la
dette sociale et pour ce qui est de la
gestion des flux financiers ce n'est pas
la cadèse mais c'est la cause qui gère
les flux financiers gérer les flux d'en
financiers c'est quoi c'est faire des
levées de fonds pourquoi la cause fait
des levées de fonds tout simplement pour
servir les prestations sociales à tous
les Français car il ne faut pas perdre
de vue que la température temporalité
des recettes sociales et fiscales n'est
pas la même que la temporalité de verser
les prestations donc pour pouvoir verser
les prestations chaque mois aux assurés
la cause lève des fonds sur les marchés
boursiers nationaux et c'est bien parce
que la France a une signature solide
qu'elle peut emprunter sur ses marchés
boursiers et c'est essentiel pour
pouvoir verser en temps réel les
prestations assurées
merci madame la députée pour ces
précisions monsieur Guedj
oui mais mes chers collègues c'est cet
amendement de nos collègues insoumis
nous permet dès à présent de parler de
la CADES comme un des leviers ou comme
un digne d'épices pouvant être mobilisés
nous aurons l'occasion de le faire un
peu plus tard à l'article 5 du projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pourquoi est-ce qu'il
est légitime
pourquoi il est au moins en séance chers
collègues pourquoi il est légitime
d'interroger la cadèse parce que là on
va se dire les choses très
tranquillement nous faisons purement et
simplement de la politique de la même
manière que dans la loi du 2 août 2020
un choix politique et uniquement
politique a été fait d'affecter la
totalité de la dette covid à la CADES un
autre choix a été possible il aurait
permis de dégager des marges de
manoeuvre et là nécessité faisant loi
nous la politique c'est faire un
arbitrage entre augmenter de deux ans le
temps de travail de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens et essayer
d'optimiser le montage on l'aime on
l'aime pas je reviens pas sur la genèse
et l'histoire de la cadette on peut la
contester dans son principe même mais
elle existe simplement on a fait un
choix de prolonger sa durée de vie de 9
ans pour absorber la totalité de cette
dette de cette dette covid la
proposition qui peut vous être faite
faire aujourd'hui et c'est en procès
c'est que sur en gros les ressources de
la cadèse où il y a la CRDS évidemment
mais aussi une fraction de la CSG et des
du rendement du fond de réserve des
retraites nous vous proposons de
distraire une partie de ce financement
là pour l'affecter au financement de la
branche vieillesse et à hauteur de 10
milliards d'euros ce qui est quand même
pas neutre sur la vingtaine de milliards
de financements de la Cadès ce qui veut
dire qu'on maintient un financement de
la cadas à hauteur de 10 milliards
d'euros et qu'une partie de la dette
CADES de la dette covid qui a été
affectée à la dette Cadès elle peut être
cantonnée dans un autre outil financier
ou alors intégré dans la dette de l'État
ce que je veux dire c'est là il y a un
choix politique purement et simplement
mais simplement on vous propose sans
augmentation des prélèvements
obligatoires de dégager une ressource
qui permettra de d'absorber quasiment la
moitié de l'effort du déficit dont on ne
conteste pas la réalité ce qu'on veut
vous montrer à travers ce type
d'amendement comme ceux qui viendront à
l'article 5 c'est que
vous nous dites il n'y a pas
d'alternative there is no alternative
vous êtes les tas de chair de la du
régime des retraites en disant on n'a
pas d'autre choix que d'allonger de deux
ans la durée de travail alors que avec
une palette d'outils dont celui-là et
avec une sophistication dans
l'utilisation de ces outils on peut
mettre à contribution un bout de la
dette de l'État on peut mettre à
contribution des salariés du revenu de
remplacement des revenus du capital on a
une palette d'outils dont on veut
essayer de vous faire la démonstration
très sincèrement qu'ils sont
mobilisables sans avoir besoin de faire
les deux années et la Cadès est un de
ces outils on passe pas tout par dessus
bord on gère longtemps
je dois gérer le temps et vous avez eu
58 minutes de plus parce que voilà 58
secondes de plus
très bien 58 secondes oui oui très très
je n'en doute pas monsieur le député
monsieur Cyril Isa
dans un débat intéressant
le débat c'est d'équilibrer les
retraites
au moins jusqu'en 2070 parce que le
corps nous dit que en 2070
j'imagine nos successeurs parce que bien
évidemment plus aucun d'entre nous
serons là
dans 50 ans
donc on est heureux de savoir que le
corps nous dit qu'en 2070 le système
sera équilibré le problème là c'est de
l'équilibrer déjà jusqu'en 2005 ans
la proposition qui est faite on pourrait
l'entendre si effectivement c'était pour
équilibrer le système de retraite s'il y
avait un mauvais passage sur un ou deux
ans c'est ce qu'on a fait effectivement
lors de la crise covid si lorsque la
feuille qui ment par rapport à la
financement de l'assurance maladie mais
l'a fait reposer
le financement des retraites jusqu'à
2050 en faisant des comme le propose
monsieur Guedj des petits ajustements
c'est-à-dire que tous les ans on sera
amené à refaire des petits ajustements
pour aller chercher 15 milliards la
solution qu'on propose c'est d'avoir et
c'est ce qu'on dit quand revient sur le
système par répartition c'est d'avoir
une pérennité c'est sauver ce système en
le périnisant et par le périnéant de ce
gage d'ici 2000 l'année prochaine ou
dans deux ans c'est de pérenniser lui
donner une solidité au moins jusqu'en
2050 je vous rappelle qu'en 1810 on est
très contents que que nos high artisans
ça sera équilibré
[Musique]
très bien je vous remercie mes chers
collègues madame la rapporteur
ah pardon Louis monsieur ménager merci
Madame présidente le rapporteur général
alors permettez-moi de faire un petit
point quand même vis-à-vis de la tenue
de nos débats il nous reste plus que 7
heures de débats il y a plus de 5000
amendements j'ai refait mes comptes j'ai
refait mes calculs il nous faudra 5
secondes par amendement donc il y a deux
choix il y a plusieurs choix qui
s'ouvrent à nous aujourd'hui soit et
nous c'est ce que nous avions proposé
mais la Présidente nous aviez expliqué
que c'était impossible puisqu'il faut le
voter bien entendu la première partie
l'examen prioritaire de l'article 7
c'est-à-dire sur le report de l'âge
légal moi je vous propose toutes et tous
que nous supprimions que nous retirions
nos amendements pour arriver à l'article
7 parce que les Français attendent que
nous parlions de cet article 7 je
propose aussi ma présidente que nous
remettions le sujet du 1 pour un contre
sur la table parce que aujourd'hui tous
les groupes sauf la news sont d'accord
pour un pour un contre nous avons face à
nous l'extrême gauche qui bloque les
débats nous les députés du rassemblement
national nous souhaitons parler du cœur
du sujet de la pénibilité du report de
l'âge légal des carrières longues nous
ne sommes pas là pour pour mettre le
bazar dans cette commission nous
souhaitons débattre du fond des sujets
et donc je vous propose que l'ensemble
des groupes premièrement retire leurs
amendements pour que nous puissions
débattre des vraies questions qui
intéressent les Français et que nous
passions sur le régime de 1 pour un
contre je pense que ce n'est pas la nups
de dicter la manière de faire les débats
dans cette commission madame la
Présidente vous avez la possibilité de
changer les règles et de mettre en place
un pour un compte donc je sollicite de
votre part que ce nouveau système soit
mis en place pour les prochains
amendements
très bien monsieur le député
c'est le troisième jour on a on a fait
un petit mini marathon je vous le dis
trois jours c'est un mini marathon la
semaine prochaine et la semaine d'après
nous serons 15 jours ce sera le
véritable marathon donc là il est 11h
changer les règles juste quelques heures
avant ça me semble quand même compliqué
j'ai fait à deux fois j'ai fait la
proposition de faire un pour un compte
ça a été voilà
retoqué et on a dit non donc voilà je
suis désolé monsieur le député mais on
va poursuivre après effectivement si
certains c'est ce qui s'est d'ailleurs
passé hier dans le cadre de la
commission défense décide de retirer de
manière
radicale certains amendements pour que
nous puissions avancer sur le débat je
veux bien mais chacun prend ses
responsabilités si on n'avance pas dans
ce débat certains seront se reconnaître
pourquoi il y a eu des redondances des
redites et on a très bien compris donc
voilà il y a même une collègue députée
qui s'est exprimée en effectivement que
quelque part on bloqué le texte voilà
donc on poursuit je mets aux voix donc
ah pardon madame
il y a déjà eu monsieur virée monsieur
bazar madame la rapporteur oui merci
madame la Présidente rapidement je
voulais répondre à Monsieur Gadge parce
que sur le fond je ne suis pas d'accord
avec ce que vous proposez parce que si
on fait ce que vous dites ça va
prolonger
la CRDS qui est le même taux pour tous
notamment les plus fragiles jusqu'au
au-delà de 2033 donc une baisse du
pouvoir d'achat des plus fragiles aussi
de tout le monde mais notamment des plus
fragiles donc je trouve que c'est pas
très bien Madame la rapporteur donc je
mets aux voix ces deux amendements
identiques
qui ont reçu un avis défavorable de
Madame la rapporteur qui est pour
alors attendez lever il y en a qui
baisse un
c'est extraordinaire comme des fois ça
fluxture parce que c'est un amusement on
se dit on va battre la majorité mais
c'est très bien 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19
très bien qui est contre
18 19 20 21 22 23 ils sont rejetés
je vous propose une petite pause de 10
minutes
très bien mes chers collègues nous
allons reprendre
donc
est-ce qu'il est défendu celui-ci oui
oui madame Youssoupha attendez je vais
vous donner le micro
madame la député merci madame la
Présidente alors cet amendement propose
de créer un abattement fiscal au profit
des retraités agricoles pour qu'il
puisse mettre en location une partie ou
l'intégralité de leur exploitation ce
qu'on appelle le fermage c'est devenu
une option pour les agriculteurs
retraités qui perçoivent un complément
de faible pension de retraite vous savez
que les retraités sont souvent en deçà
du seuil de pauvreté au niveau national
c'est encore pire dans les outre-mer un
Mayotte je rappelle que
la retraite est en moyenne à 280 euros
la plus faible retraite versée à Mayotte
est à 9 euros seulement pour nous qui
reposons considérablement sur le secteur
agricole cette mesure est importante
une option d'imposition est très forte
pour le fermage à travers cet amendement
nous souhaitons faire bénéficier des
agriculteurs retraités d'un empattement
de la CSG à hauteur de 25% plafonnée à
20000 € pour la location de leur
exploitation agricole je vous remercie
très bien Madame la rapporteur votre
avis sur cet amendement merci madame la
Présidente l'assiette de la CSG est
assis sur les pensions de retraite
permet à notre système de protection
sociale de bénéficier d'une ressource
d'environ 8,3 milliards par an c'est
considérable je veux toutefois appeler
que la CSG sur les pensions de retraite
est moduler en fonction du niveau de la
retraite tous les retraités ne paient
pas la même siège il existe quatre taux
dont une exonération allant jusqu'à un
taux maximal de
8,3%. il me semble donc ce système est
déjà très progressif et qui n'est pas
nécessaire de créer une nouvelle
exonération de CSG au risque de
déstabiliser le financement de notre
système de retraite
très bien alors madame minier
la présidente notre avis sur cette
proposition est mitigée c'est vrai vous
avez raison les retraites agricoles sont
faibles et en particulier à Mayotte
comme j'ai pu le constater
mais les paysans ne devraient pas avoir
à courir après des compléments parce que
leur pension n'est pas suffisante il
devrait être sûr que le et il faudrait
être sûr que le fermage en question
permet de libérer du foncier pour des
nouveaux exploitants quand on sait qu'un
paysan sur deux partira en retraite dans
10 ans nous avons besoin de faciliter
l'installation mais il faudrait avoir il
faudrait pouvoir vérifier que cette
mesure aurait un impact significatif sur
l'installation et qu'elle ne favorise
pas l'investissement spéculatif sur le
foncier plus globalement donc votre
réforme aide à pas en rien à stimuler
l'installation en agriculture allonger
la durée de cotisation et reporter l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite ne
favorisera pas à la transmission de de
la moitié des fermes actuelles dans les
10 ans à venir et l'installation de
paysans et paysanne nécessaire pour
répondre aux enjeux sociaux et
environnementaux et concernant
l'augmentation des minimum de pension
croyez moi cette effet d'annonce les
paysans et paysannes l'ont déjà connu
résultat il y a beaucoup d'entre eux
aujourd'hui à la retraite qui ont
toujours une pension inférieure à 1000
euros et les critères de la loi
châtaignent un exclut de nombreux
paysans et paysannes de la pension à 85%
du SMIC pour les chefs d'exploitation
une preuve de plus que cette réforme que
que cette réforme des retraites que vous
essayez d'imposer au peuple ne répond
pas aux réalités du terrain alors que
18% des ménages agricoles vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté la solution n'est pas
de faire de les faire travailler plus
longtemps
très bien monsieur Bazin
oui merci
collègue c'est un amendement sur la CSG
sur les
sur les retraités finalement nous
rappelle
des dispositions qui ont pénalisé le
pouvoir d'achat des retraités je pense
aux mesures qui ont été prises sous le
précédent quinquennat et qui ont
d'ailleurs suscité en plus de des
augmentations de taxes sur l'essence du
80 km/h le mouvement des gilets jaunes
alors ça a fait reculer le gouvernement
sur cette hausse de la CSG sur les
retraités mais que partiellement parce
qu'en fait des couples de classe moyenne
se retrouvent avec un taux de CSG qui a
deux fait augmenter et et ces
problématiques j'ai eu des témoignages
dans ma circonscription mais je sais que
que mes collègues je pense à mon voisin
Fabien di FIBO a eu la même chose des
couples parce qu'ils sont en couple pas
de bol alors qu'ils ont des petites
retraites parfois une femme à moins de 7
à moins de 1000 euros de retraite mais
comme elle est en couple avec quelqu'un
qui a mis le héros de retraite mais en
fait le total fait que et c'est une des
spécificités de la CSG pour les
retraités c'est qu'elle est considéré au
niveau du couple et et oui mais c'est
vous ne te répondez c'est le système
mais aujourd'hui on a effectivement eu
des mesures qui ont baissé le pouvoir
d'achat des retraités et sinon on a une
ligne rouge qui est importante c'est de
pas baisser le pouvoir d'achat de
retraité et c'est pas de baisser non
plus le salaire net des salariés donc il
faut vraiment améliorer le taux d'emploi
déjà des seniors des maires de famille
c'est vraiment le vecteur pour moi pour
trouver les solutions et on le voit bien
d'ailleurs dans le rapport du corps une
des hypothèses si on veut la pérennité
c'est un taux d'emploi qui serait à 5%
dans les hypothèses dans les
trajectoires et un renouvellement des
générations or l'auto-emploi on n'a pas
créé les conditions pour l'améliorer et
sur le renouvellement des générations on
n'a pas créé les conditions le climat de
confiance pour que les nouvelles
générations les jeunes croient en
l'avenir accueille la vie accueille des
enfants et et que derrière on est des
futurs cotisants pour assurer le régime
ça passe par le travail ça passe par le
renouvellement des générations
très bien monsieur turquois
merci madame la Présidente est-ce qu'il
y a un problème sur le niveau des
pensions agricoles oui mais la solution
toujours utilisée si vous raisonnez à
taille du gâteau constant et donc il
faudrait réduire ici ou là tel fiscalité
pour l'affecter ici ou là a-t-elle
catégorie qui en bénéficierait et on par
ce genre de disposition on va encore
complexifier le droit rural qui l'est
déjà extrêmement et ça n'a rien à voir
avec les retraites travaillons pour que
les agriculteurs en général gagnent
mieux leur vie seul Mayotte et des
Outre-mer particulièrement il y a un
vrai sujet ça n'a pas un rapport avec
les retraites si on a une si on a un bon
revenu au cours de la carrière alors on
a une retraite qui sera plus confortable
on aurait pu évoquer la question de la
complexité du régime de retraite
agricole qui est sans nom je l'ai évoqué
là au moment où notre collègue avait
porté pour
aligner le régime agricole sur le calcul
des 25 meilleures années ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui mais avec un
système tel qu'il est construit
actuellement en matière agricole qui qui
incite pas à cotiser davantage puisque
il est il est très il est extrêmement
solidaire entre agriculteur pro et
agriculteurs très pauvres donc
réfléchissons sur ces sujets qui sont
spécifiques retraite vous avez évoqué
aussi la loi Chassaigne et pourquoi un
certain nombre n'en parle droit et bien
parce que la complexité de notre système
de retraite tout confondu on a des
agriculteurs qui ont cotisé dans
d'autres régimes et ça ça emmène des
blocages sur la revalorisation châtaigne
il faut simplifier notre système il faut
unifier les règles d'un système à
l'autre ça ça serait un vrai travail de
fond à faire qui serait pertinent pour
tous les retraités futurs retraités
donc défavorable à cet amendement très
bien donc je mets aux voix cette
amendement qui a reçu madame la
rapporteur vous souhaitez peut-être dire
un mot non je mets aux voix cet
amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour
alors d'accord qui est contre
il est rejeté merci mes chers collègues
amendement identique monsieur Guedj
dans la palette des outils que nous
cherchons à mobiliser pour alimenter la
branche vieillesse sans avoir à recourir
à cette impôt sur la vie que constitue
les deux années supplémentaires nous
vous proposons à l'instant une un
rehaussement du taux de la CSG sur les
revenus du capital actuellement à
9,2%
ça représente
environ 10% des revenus de la CSG
et cette augmentation d'un point des
revenus enfin du taux de CSG permettrait
d'abonder et
la branche la branche vieillesse c'est
pas une somme gigantesque un point de un
point de de CSG c'est environ un
rendement de de 15 milliards d'euros 10%
donc vous voyez à peu près la somme que
nous que nous proposons mais nous
considérons que les des ruisseaux feront
les grandes rivières et que plutôt que
cette
taxation sur la vie des gens on peut
diversifier diversifier les ressources
les revenus du capital ainsi mis à
contribution permettront là aussi
indirectement de rééquilibrer la
fiscalité du capital dont on rappelle
que depuis le début du quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron elle a singulièrement
été
allégé nous avons parlé tout à l'heure
de l'ISF nous pourrions parler de la
flat tax
et de ce prélèvement forfaitaire unique
qui a vu ainsi baisser la taxation du du
capital donc voilà une des propositions
que nous vous faisons et qui ne devrait
pas déclencher des réactions
passionnées c'est une un abondement
mesuré avec tous les autres que nous
proposons et qui permettront
d'équilibrer
le débat avant alors c'est bien madame
madame non non
identiques madame la rapporte
qui défend le 6118 oui allez-y madame la
députée merci madame la Présidente on ne
le répétera jamais assez et les Français
l'ont d'ailleurs bien compris le déficit
prévisionnel des régimes de retraite en
2030 est limité entre 0,4 et 08 points
de PIB et il peut facilement être comblé
nous vous proposons ici une piste de
financement parmi d'autres augmenter la
CSG sur les revenus du capital rappelons
que les revenus du capital ne sont
soumis depuis 2018 qu'un taux de
prélèvement de 30%, le prélèvement
forfaitaire unique dont 9,2 % de CSG de
ce fait les revenus du capital sont
largement moins imposés que les revenus
du travail il serait plus légitime
d'augmenter la CSG sur les revenus du
capital pour éviter le report de l'âge
légal une mesure injuste et inutile dans
les Français ne veulent pas
très bien amendement suivant monsieur
d'arriville merci madame la Présidente
tout à l'heure notre collègue Nicolas
turquois sur l'amendement précédent
disait
vous avez tort de raisonner avec la
taille du gâteau constant et je partage
cette opinion avec lui peut-être qu'on
n'est pas d'accord sur beaucoup de
choses par ailleurs mais l'objectif de
cet amendement c'est bien d'élargir en
tout cas la part de ce sur quoi porte un
certain nombre de de ressources
si on a un bon revenu au cours de la
carrière a-t-il également précisé on a
une retraite plus confortable il part
les agriculteurs je le précise mais je
pense qu'on devrait appliquer ça de
manière plus générale je ferme la
parenthèse à l'ensemble des salariés
concernant cet amendement bon il a été
défendu par mes collègues précédemment
vous savez que la CSG sur les revenus
d'activité et de remplacement donc
salaire et pension de retraite à a été
augmenté de 1,7 points 2018 pour
financer la baisse de cotisation sociale
chômage maladie tandis que la CSG sur
les revenus du capital à seulement été
augmenté de 1 point je rappelle que
cette mesure avait été
avec provoqué une vie émotion dans le
pays une vie colère une vive passion
pour reprendre le mot de mon collègue
Jérôme Guedj et que les retraités
c'était fortement mobilisés je pense que
c'est d'ailleurs un des éléments qui
avait aussi qu'on conduit au mouvement
des des gilets jaunes donc et cette
augmentation conduisait les retraités à
financer eux-mêmes leur retraite en
cotisant bon ce qui était quand même là
aussi assez croquignolé donc nous
proposons à travers cet amendement
d'augmenter la CSG sur les revenus du
capital de 2,8 points une telle
progression permettait un rendement
supplémentaire de 3 milliards d'euros au
profit des caisses de sécurité sociale
très bien merci Madame la rapporteur
votre avis sur ces trois amendements oui
merci ces amendements proposent
d'augmenter la CSG sur les revenus du
capital c'est ça s'imposera par exemple
au 14 millions de Français qui ont un
plan d'épargne logement monsieur Gadge
la rappeler ce taux est déjà de 9,2 %
permet de rapporter 16 milliards d'euros
à notre système de protection sociale et
surtout sans bouger le taux on voit que
le rendement est dynamique et augmenté
après une forte hausse en 2021 on était
à plus 12% la CSG prélevée sur les
revenus du capital continuera
d'augmenter en 2022 à plus 9,2%. il n'y
a donc à mon avis aucune raison
particulière d'augmenter ce taux donc
défavorable très bien j'ai plusieurs
demandes de parole monsieur legabre
oui en appui à ses amendements qui
montrent clairement qu'il n'y a pas dès
lors qu'on le veut évidemment de
problèmes de financement des retraites
et je voudrais revenir de ce point de
vue sur un aspect du débat qui est en
cours on a beaucoup entendu
dans les minutes qui viennent de
s'écouler
les promoteurs des exonérations de
cotisations sociales et dette publique
aux entreprises
moyen qui nous est présenté comme un
moyen infaillible pour notamment lutter
contre le chômage
alors juste un fait parce que les faits
c'est quand même la meilleure manière de
départager ce genre de débat je vais
prendre un exemple tout simple c'est
l'exemple de Sanofi Sanofi est en 2022 à
empocher l'équivalent d'un milliard 8
sous forme d’être public aux entreprises
il a empoché ses aides et la même année
sanofi a procédé à une délocalisation de
son secteur recherche d'une partie de
son secteur recherche en tout cas aux
États-Unis et une délocalisation d'une
partie de sa production employant les
travailleurs les moins qualifiés vers
l'Inde mais les 1 milliard 8 en revanche
Sanofi les a pris et les amis dans sa
poche voilà à quoi ça sert donc cette
politique en réalité
aboutit à un résultat assécher toujours
plus les caisses de la Sécu et les
caisses de retraite et ça conduit un des
associations je rappelle quand même
qu'il y a dans ce pays 10 millions de
travailleurs pauvres et il faut pas
s'étonner si hier en particulier il y
avait près de 3 millions de personnes
dans les rues il faut pas s'étonner si
la contestation sociale contre le contre
votre projet de réforme des retraites
est aussi importantes nul doute que
cette contestation ne va pas refluer et
en tout cas pour nous nous allons à
notre modeste place tout faire pour
qu'elle ne refuse pas et pour qu'au
contraire elle s'amplifie et pour vous
contraindre à retirer votre projet de
réforme des retraites monsieur dit
Philippot vous avez la parole monsieur
le député oui merci madame la Présidente
simplement pour dire que je comprends la
gauche qui est toujours dans une logique
de socialisation des revenus et de
transfert et de redistribution
mais ayez bien conscience d'une chose il
y a beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui y
compris parmi les classes moyennes qui
travaillent et qui savent que avec le
système de retraite des pensions
confortables ne sont pas garanties et
que sans doute et bien l'avenir ce sera
de plus en plus compliqué qui doivent
épargner qui doivent capitaliser pour
pouvoir et bien avoir un niveau de vie
juste acceptable et pour avoir des
projets à la retraite c'est aussi ces
personnes là que vous attaquez avec ce
type d'augmentation des taxes et donc il
faut en tenir en tenir compte on est pas
riche quand on gagne plus de 1500 ou de
2000 euros par mois
très bien monsieur Petavy
merci madame la Présidente
notre collègue Prisca thèmeau tout à
l'heure utiliser des mots assez
terribles avec ceux qui réussissent
et voilà oui vous parliez de ceux qui
réussissent tout à l'heure oui voilà et
oui c'est bien voilà voilà votre projet
en fait aider ceux qui réussissent et
c'est bien là toute la différence entre
vous et nous
que tous oui mais elle a parlé de ceux
qui réussissent voilà et en fait c'est
très violent et je crois que vous ne
prenez pas la mesure de la violence de
ces mots madame ma collègue Rachel kéké
hier parler
monsieur le député revenait à
l'amendement
hier du mépris c'est précisément ça
cette question du mépris c'est une
violence terrible et votre projet parce
que si on se pose la question de d'où
vient justement la réussite alors
l'héritage être bien né donc on voit
bien quand même d'où ça vient cette
histoire là et les autres alors
puisque c'est de ça dont il est question
et c'est de ça dont on parle depuis
maintenant deux jours et les autres
parce que dès qu'elle est l'âge légal
donc de départ de départ à la retraite
rajouter deux ans bien ceux qui ont fait
des études ça ne va rien leur changer en
fait avec le modèle actuel et qui va le
payer justement ceux qui dans votre
dénomination non pas réussi et qu'est-ce
qui va être payé c'est le corps
justement
c'est l'invalidité c'est l'usure c'est
la fatigue c'est la vie et voilà cette
question là donc effectivement il faut
que l'on arrive à trouver un système
beaucoup plus juste et c'est la nature
de cette amendement merci
très bien monsieur vous avez changé
monsieur mournet c'est Madame Thévenot
très bien
merci merci madame la présidente Madame
la rapporteur chers collègues aucun
mépris de ma part une simple réalité
pour savoir où on va et notamment avec
la réforme que nous proposons il faut
savoir d'où on part et aujourd'hui moi
je j'aimerais rappeler tout ce que vous
nous avez dit depuis quelques jours
parce qu'on écoute bien évidemment et ce
que vous nous dites c'est qu'aujourd'hui
le système ne permet pas justement
personne que vous citez à très juste
titre d'avoir une retraite assurée une
fois qu'ils l'auront mérité parce que
oui le travail dur doit pouvoir
permettre d'avoir une retraite saine et
aujourd'hui les pénibilités les
carrières longues oui ce n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui vous avez raison
monsieur et c'est pour ça que je vous
invite je vous invite à faire oeuvre de
travail et considérer que nous sommes là
aujourd'hui pour répondre à ces
problématiques de carrière longue de
pénibilité du sujet des femmes au moment
de la retraite est-ce que vous nous
proposez aujourd'hui ce n'est pas de
travailler mais c'est de travailler sur
le texte je veux dire mais bien de
rejeter en bloc servez-vous de cet outil
législatif pour améliorer la condition
des femmes et des hommes avec qui vous
avez défilé hier
très bien monsieur Monet
merci Madame A rapporteur je comprends
pas votre réponse en fait
l'amendement présenté par Pierre
consensus puisque on vous propose
d'élargir la cotisation et d'augmenter
la cotisation et vous nous dites ça ne
nécessite pas si le déficit à venir le
nécessite et donc on vous propose bien
de la cotisation donc pas du budget de
là mais de la cotisation et d'augmenter
la cotisation c'est un moyen de faire
rentrer de l'argent pour les retraites
par contre madame la députée j'ai pour
bien comprendre votre réalité j'aimerais
bien que vous me définissiez selon vous
ce qui ne réussissent pas à qui
pensez-vous
parce que moi je pense que vous pensez à
ceux qui ont manifesté hier mais
peut-être que je me trompe vous pas mais
je vous demande donc vous allez me
répondre vous me dites vous parlez de
ceux qui réussissent moi je vous demande
de définir ce selon vous ce qui ne
réussissent pas
qui sont-ils qui sont-ils ceux qui ne
réussissent pas qui sont-ils selon vous
très bien monsieur Colombani
merci madame la Présidente donc c'est un
amendement
identique nous avions déposé à l'article
7 avec notre groupe qui ne sera pas
examiné vraisemblablement donc il
propose encore une fois un autre mode de
financement plutôt que se baser
uniquement sur le reportage légal donc
la CSG vous l'avez vous l'avez rappelé
elle a augmenté sur le revenu du capital
mais pas la même vitesse que sur les
revenus d'activité de remplacement donc
ce n'est qu'une mesure de justice
sociale en fait et donc nous on est tout
à fait favorable à cette à cet
amendement
très bien monsieur Gernigon
oui juste une réaction par rapport à des
propos qui ont été tenus en disant que
la réussite il fallait être dans une
famille biennée non non on peut pas
entendre des choses comme ça ça veut
dire quoi dans une famille biennée je
crois que réussir c'est simplement avoir
le sens du travail la valeur travail le
goût de l'effort et ça c'est une
question d'éducation c'est pas une
question d'argent
très bien Madame la rapporteur général
seul madame la rapporteur à la à la
parole
je voudrais je voudrais répondre à
Monsieur Monet
répondre à Monsieur money parce que j'ai
peut-être pas été assez clair cet
amendement propose d'augmenter la
taxation la CSG donc une taxe non c'est
une taxe la CSG c'est pas cotisation et
donc vous voulez bien taxer 14 millions
de Français notamment qui ont un projet
un PEL mais c'est ce que fait
l'amendement je dis pas en tout cas moi
mon boulot de rapporteur c'est ce que de
dire ce que fait l'amendement cet
amendement taxe au moins 14 millions de
Français qui ont un peu très bien
monsieur Guedj
ce débat est passionnant donc nous
assumons en effet de taxer davantage les
revenus du capital sauf que la réalité
de ces revenus du capital madame la
rapporteur vous pouvez exciter les 14
millions de Français qui sont détenteurs
d'un PEL mais la réalité des revenus du
capital en France ce n'est ce ne sont
pas les revenus générés par le PEL dont
je rappelle qui les rémunéré à 1%
l'essentiel des revenus du capital
l'essentiel des revenus du capital en
France c'est quoi ce sont les dividendes
d'action c'est l'épargne salariale et ce
sont les plus-values mobilières les
plus-values mobilières en France c'est
15 milliards d'euros et vous savez c'est
15 milliards d'euros de plus-values
mobilières c'est concentré à 71% sur
3900 foyers donc les revenus du capital
bien sûr qu'il y a des il y a des
revenus du capital pour les ménages et
pour les classes moyennes mais ils sont
dérisoires au regard de l'extrême
concentration du capital en France
capital mobilier et immobilier et que
taxer les revenus du capital c'est
précisément un peu plus c'est
précisément mettre davantage à
contribution ce qui génère à peu près
80% des revenus de du capital donc vous
allez nous agiter on voit bien l'élément
de langage les 14 millions de Français
qui sont détenteurs d'un PEL mais c'est
pas eux qui génèrent le flux des revenus
du capital je vous redonne ce chiffre 15
milliards d'euros de plus-values
mobilières dont unique dont
3900 foyers fiscaux concentrent 71%
c'est à dire 10 milliards de ses
plus-values mobilières c'est eux que
nous voulons mettre à contribution et
c'est eux que vous avez épargné d'une
certaine manière en mettant en place la
flat taxe et le prélèvement forfaitaire
unique donc de grâce venez pas nous
agiter le capital des classe moyenne et
des classes populaires c'est
essentiellement le capital des ménages
les plus aisés que nous souhaitons
mettre à contribution très bien monsieur
le député donc sur ce je vais mettre ces
trois amendements identiques aux voix
qui est pour qui ont reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur qui
est pour qui est contre
ils sont rejetés
amendements pouvant être soumis à une
discussion commune monsieur Daredevil
pour le 7118
oui merci madame la Présidente je
permets simplement d'acter qu'en
l'occurrence il s'agissait d'une mesure
de justice qui voulait taxer au même
niveau le capital et le travail ce qui
est une des mesures de financement
nécessaire et que vous y refusez je
regrette franchement que depuis le début
de l'examen de ces articles de ses
amendements de ce matin vous écartez une
à une toutes les pistes de financement
possible pour finalement nous expliquer
qu'il y a que la vôtre qui qui peut
fonctionner bon évidemment on a un
désaccord fondamental là-dessus donc
l'amendement que je défends cette
fois-ci vis à revenir sur l'allègement
de la fiscalité sur les actions
gratuites je rappelle que ça avait été
adoptée un peu au débotté comme ça dans
une sorte d'excitation soudaine de
l'Assemblée avec un amendement déposé en
dernière minute qui avait du coup
alléger la fiscalité sur les actions
gratuites de manière massive pour
encourager la distribution d'action
gratuite ce qui est quand même là aussi
un problème du point de vue de la
structure de la propriété de l'économie
dans dans notre pays donc ce dispositif
qui permet l'attribution gratuite
d'action concerne essentiellement je le
rappelle je fais de la prévention des
salariés très bien rémunérés de grands
groupes et les dirigeants et outre un
coup non négligeable pour les finances
publiques sociales les finances sociales
pardon il s'agit d'un outil de
contournement du salaire qui peut être
utilisé par un certain nombre de
d'employeurs et c'est pourquoi les
auteurs ne s'abandent de cet amendement
propose de ramener la contribution
patronale au taux de 30% ce qui aurait
plusieurs vertus y compris de ramener un
certain nombre de rémunérations vers le
salaire et donc de la cotisation
très bien
amendement suivant pas défendu
amendement monsieur dit Philippot
non il est parti d'accord et bien
écoutez madame le rapporteur vous avez
la parole merci madame la Présidente je
suis pas sûr que vous ayez
défendu peut-être le bon amendement
c'est amendement prévoit de revenir un
taux de CSG de 6,6% pour les retraités
donc vous proposez de diminuer le taux
normal de CSG sur les retraites de 8,3 à
6,6%. je rappelle que ce tonner pas le
seul comme je l'ai dit il existe une
modulation mais que les pensions
bénéficient donc de quatre taux
différents dont une exonération en
fonction du niveau des pensions il
s'agit là d'un système juste progressif
que je crois indispensable de maintenir
donc avis défavorable
très bien monsieur Clouet
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente on a
entendu des propos un petit peu
étonnants depuis quelques minutes on
nous dit tout le monde peut réussir
finalement lorsqu'on veut on peut alors
c'est incompréhensible parce que les
pauvres n'ont pas compris que ils
pouvaient réussir il pouvait devenir
milliardaire moi je vous crois
aveuglément vous le savez bien alors
j'ai été regarder un petit peu la liste
des grandes fortunes françaises en me
disant lesquelles ce sont extraits par
leur travail d'une condition initiale
défavorable pour devenir la force du
poignet des capitaines d'industrie
d'entreprises et de la finance alors
j'ai regardé le parcours de Monsieur
Arnaud monsieur Sade monsieur Pinault
monsieur verttimer ou monsieur beignet
et j'ai pas trouvé j'ai pas trouvé les
années au SMIC j'ai pas trouvé les jobs
étudiants j'ai pas trouvé les heures sup
alors j'ai trouvé des écoles privées qui
généralement sont hors de prix pour
n'importe qui qui vit de son travail
j'ai trouvé des actions données par la
famille ça oui tout à fait
j'ai trouvé de l'héritage d'entreprise
ça oui tout à fait mais alors je cherche
encore où est le travail qui leur a
permis de partir de rien pour s'élever à
tout parce que en l'occurrence il me
semble que la réalité monte que ce qui
naissent avec tout et bien finissent
aussi avec tout c'est bien pour ça qu'il
faut leur reprendre
très bien monsieur Bazin
merci madame la Présidente dans cette
discussion
moi j'ai l'impression qu'on a entendre
certains de mes collègues on parle soit
que des grandes fortunes soit que des
personnes en précarité mais entre les
deux on oublie la plupart de nos
concitoyens et et moi je suis heurté
quand on dit que tout serait lié au
déterminisme social à l'héritage au fait
d'être bien né ou pas d'ailleurs je ne
sais pas ce que ça veut dire être bien
né moi je crois au mériterai plus bien
au travail et et je suis convaincu que
ce n'est ni la fortune ni loisiveté qui
vont assurer l'équilibre durable de
notre système et quand Olivier Faure
attaque la tyrannie du mérite
franchement
on peut aujourd'hui réussir et notre
pacte social va tenir si ceux qui sont
en état ce qui le peuvent ce qui en sont
en âge contribuent par leur travail à
produire de la richesse afin d'assurer
notre système de protection sociale et
et et je veux dire c'est un ensemble qui
se tient de droits et de devoirs et un
parcours méritocratique de justice se
fondent sur le sur le travail sur les
efforts et et ça donne confiance dans
notre système à la présidence monsieur
dare
oui merci madame la Présidente
effectivement madame la rapporteur j'ai
pas réussi à tromper votre vigilance et
je me suis trompé de d'amendements
cela dit vous l'aviez très bien décrit
vous-même et effectivement il vise à
revenir sur la mesure que nous avons
tant critiquée qui a été cette
augmentation de la CSG et qui avait
provoqué une grande colère parmi les
retraités parce qu'elle venait s'ajouter
en plus à une stagnation des des
pensions qui duraient depuis plusieurs
années et qui a donc à la singulièrement
dégradée leur pouvoir d'achat leur
pouvoir de vivre donc je maintiens que
en réalité si vous n'avez pas voulu
augmenter d'ailleurs la fiscalité tout à
l'heure la CSG sur le sur le capital de
notre côté vous pourriez au moins
consentir à revenir sur une mesure que
le premier ministre de l'époque lui-même
avait reconnu comme étant une erreur
si je me souviens bien tardivement est
trop tardivement puisse ça n'avait pas
amené à ensuite la remettre en cause
mais si vous allez au bout de cette de
cette analyse là je pense que vous
devriez aujourd'hui voter cet amendement
voilà c'est reconnaître que ouais
c'était pas la meilleure idée que vous
avez eu bon après il y en a d'autres des
mauvaises idées mais au moins celle-là
voilà donc après on pourrait discuter
longuement avec Monsieur Bazin de la
place accordée dans le projet de société
de la droite au mérite et à ce qu'on a
parce que certains appellent la
méritocratie moi je suis aussi monté à
la tribune de l'Assemblée nationale pour
critiquer cette conception des choses
qui fait que certains méritent et
d'autres non et je pense qu'on peut pas
avoir cette conception là des choses et
que c'est une conception inégalitaire de
la société voilà alors ça veut pas dire
que nous sommes différents les uns les
autres ne vont pas les mêmes parcours de
vie mais chacun chacune doit avoir des
droits et moi c'est cette société là que
je défends voilà
très bien monsieur Vigier
oui merci madame la Présidente non
simplement une réaction par rapport à ce
que j'ai entendu tout à l'heure
franchement d'ailleurs pierre dériville
il avait un peu pondéré les mots
monsieur connaît bien je connaissons
parcours la méritocratie c'est pas un
gros mot le fait que des hommes et des
femmes puissent démarrer complètement en
bas de l'échelle les grandir c'est
s'épanouir ça n'est pas un gros mot on
peut reprocher à bien rare de beaucoup
de choses j'aurais simplement dire quand
même qu'il aura créé 15000 emplois cette
année en France c'est pas mal et 40000
dans le monde entier et moi je pense
qu'il y a de nombreux petits artisans à
des commerçants à des gens conçus se
développer regardez un groupe commandos
comment comment a commencé en dros dans
les années 50 chers collègues à la
limite de du département du Lot et de la
Corrèze ils étaient 10 ils sont combien
actuellement 50000 dans le monde
interroger leurs salariés est-ce qu'ils
sont maltraités ils ne le sont pas c'est
un message dévastateur vous faites
passer je crois que on a quelque chose
en partage en partage ces différents
sortes d'apporter les meilleures
conditions de retraite de vie à
l'ensemble de nos compatriotes mais ne
stigmatisez pas n'opposez pas les uns
aux autres arrêtez de faire ces
fractures permanentes
très bien
je mets aux voix donc cet amendement qui
a reçu un avis défavorable de Madame la
rapporteur
si Madame Rousseau oui
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
je voudrais juste rappeler une base sur
ce sur ce débat sur la mairie sur la
méritocratie c'est qu'en fait il
n'existe pas de méritocratie
individuelle et il n'existe pas
d'individus plus d'individus méritants
sans des services publics sans l'accès à
une école publique sans l'accès à des à
des hôpitaux publics sans une santé sans
un investissement qui permet de donner
des droits à chacun et une égalité de
réussite et non pas sur la base d'un
capital social que nous avons acquis de
nos parents et des générations
précédentes et en fait c'est de cela
dont il s'agit y compris dans cette
réforme des retraites puisque là ce que
vous proposez c'est que précisément ceux
qui n'ont pas bénéficié d'un ascenseur
social que vous détruisez petit à petit
à force de diminuer les investissements
sur les sur les services publics et bien
vous favorisez ceux qui évidemment ont
des métiers qui sont plus faciles qui
peuvent leur permettre de tenir jusqu'à
64 ans vous Ségré au fond ceux qui n'ont
pas les moyens de physique moraux et pas
les métiers pour tenir jusqu'à 64 ans et
en fait la socialisation du revenu la
socialisation d'une manière générale du
risque dans notre société c'est
précisément de faire en sorte que
quelque soit notre situation nous ayons
les mêmes droits et c'est ça la
méritocratie la méritocratie avoir les
mêmes droits quel que soit notre
situation
très bien
donc Monsieur Christophe
oui merci Président on entend comme des
choses assez hallucinantes parfois dans
nos débats parce que si j'ai bien
compris le concept développé par notre
collègue donc réussir sa vie c'est être
riche j'aimerais écouter j'ai pas le
sentiment qu'il faut forcément être
riche pour réussir sa vie parce que
sinon c'est inquiétant et ce sera
d'autant plus inquiétant que pour vous
réussir sa vie c'est être riche donc il
faut couper la tête des riches donc il y
aura plus de riches donc il y aura
personne va réussir sa vie alors votre
concept vraiment est étonnant après oui
je vous rejoins mabrousseau j'espère
bien qu'il faut pas faire forcément
forcément sortir de l'école privée pour
réussir sa vie je pense qu'on a assez
d'exemples autour de nous les gens sont
sortis des clubs publics et ont réussi
la vie même si je j'ai pu voir ici hier
que certains d'être les bandes sont
aussi sortis d'école privée donc il y a
rien à faire en tout ça
je suis très heureux que Philippe
Philippe Vigier site aussi l'entreprise
Andros parce que c'est un exemple
effectivement de réussite familiale qui
a qui aujourd'hui
et je vais me permettre de les citer
aussi parce qu'ils sont exemplaires
aussi sur l'inclusion notamment sur le
fait du travail dans le monde du
handicap et je pense que là aussi c'est
peut-être un autre modèle de réussite
que voir que sociétalement peut faire
grandir une entreprise avec l'inclusion
en perspective
très bien Madame
ibora j'ai demandé je me suis allée et
Madame Bora elle est Madame madame Bora
allez-y rapidement
moi je voudrais appeler que ce qu'a fait
le gouvernement de gauche en 2013 pour
la réforme des retraites
il a allongé la durée de cotisation ce
qui vient dire que on travaille plus
longtemps qu'on le veuille ou non mais
en même temps il a augmenté les impôts
et en même temps il a baissé les
pensions donc si vous voulez là on a un
exemple de ce que peut faire un
gouvernement de gauche et si aujourd'hui
on entend aller chercher l'argent là où
il est comme dit comme dit une grande
centrale syndicale c'est ce que vous
reprenez souvent ce sont des vieilles
lunes et des Français à plusieurs
reprises ont expliqué qu'il n'était pas
d'accord sinon Mélenchon était premier
ministre or c'est pas le cas d'en
changer de discours s'il vous plaît
parce que ça nous fatigue et ça fait pas
avancer la situation ni le problème
très bien Madame la Députée nous allons
donc passer aux voix je mets aux voix
cet amendement 7118 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur
général qui est pour
deux trois
12 13
20 21 22 25
très bien qui est contre
de 23 24 25 26 il est adopté
madame madame Youssoupha
monsieur Colombani allez-y merci Madame
Présidente
c'est amendement propose de revenir donc
sur la hausse de la CSG votée en loi de
finance 2018 en effet le gouvernement
donc avec augmenté de 1,7 points de CSG
provoquant donc la perte de pouvoir
d'achat importante chez les retraites et
les fonctionnaires ainsi après la crise
sociale de 2019 le gouvernement a fixé
le seuil à 2000 euros mensuel en dessous
duquel les retraités ne sont plus
assujettis au taux de CSG c'est un monde
tant à retenir un seuil de 3000 euros
mensuel qui permettrait de redonner le
pouvoir d'achat un peu plus de pouvoir
d'achat au retraité c'est dans cet
amendement est proposé par ma collègue
Estelle Youssoupha
très bien Madame la rapporteur votre
avis oui on vient d'avoir le même débat
donc c'est un avis défavorable très bien
monsieur Léo man
merci madame la Présidente c'est
difficile de prendre la parole dans
cette salle il y a pas de place
je veux revenir sur plusieurs choses
parce que quand même quand je vous
entends parler de Bernard Arnault comme
d'un type formidable j'ai envie de vous
dire allez voir les ouvrières de poids
du Nord allez voir c'est 142 femmes dont
il a fermé l'entreprise pour délocaliser
en Pologne la fabrication des costumes
Kenzo ça coûtait 100 euros à fabriquer
en France ça coûtait 30 euros à
fabriquer en Pologne et pour son profit
personnel oui Monsieur Bernard Arnault a
détruit la vie de 142 femmes 242
familles et Monsieur Bernard Arnault
quand vous parlez de la valeur travail
quand vous nous dites la valeur travail
vous n'avez que ce mot là à la bouche
mais le travail de qui des gens
détruisent le travail des autres pour
leur profit personnel voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire et maintenant je
voudrais vous dire autre chose plus
calmement en reprenant le rapport du
corps parce qu'on parle beaucoup de ce
rapport page 35 du rapport du corps à
partir de 2032 les scénarios économiques
sont bâtis à partir d'hypothèses bla
blabla l'évolution de la productivité
horaire du travail est censé déterminer
l'évolution de la rémunération horaire
du travail dès lors qu'il est fait
l'hypothèse d'une stabilité du partage
de la valeur ajoutée entre le capital et
le travail page 46 du rapport du corps
l'hypothèse d'un partage stable des
gains de productivité entre capital et
travail blablabla le partage entre le
capital et le travail et relativement
stable en France même si la part du
travail a légèrement augmenté depuis la
crise de 2008 qu'est-ce que nous sommes
en train de faire ici et que vous dit le
rapport du corps le rapport du corps
vous dit que il y a désormais une
stabilité et voir une augmentation des
gains qui vont vers le capital plutôt
que vers le travail si vous refusez de
taxer le capital comme nous vous le
proposons vous êtes donc en train de
faire baisser les recettes qui vont pour
le système des retraites je vous dis
juste une chose si on taxé les
dividendes comme le travail on récupère
48 milliards d'euros vous avez là quatre
fois votre réforme des retraites et donc
le fait que vous refusiez de taxer le
capital c'est la signature précisément
que vous n'aimez pas la valeur travail
très bien monsieur à l'oseille
je reviens sur l'amendement précédente
donc on a on a reculé donc sur la CSG on
est revenu de 8,3 % à 6,6% pour pour les
retraités donc pierre Daredevil a pas
tout dit tout à l'heure cette réforme a
beaucoup fait parler à l'époque
effectivement mais on était revenu en
partie sur cette réforme ce n'est qu'on
a augmenté le seuil 2200 euros à 2000
euros pour une personne seule et 3000
euros donc on vient de baisser la CSG on
a pris prétexte des gens effectivement
quand on a 2000 euros pour une personne
seule c'est pas énorme enfin c'est un
peu mieux que beaucoup d'autres gens et
3000 euros pour un couple c'est mieux
que beaucoup d'autres gens donc on vient
de baisser la CSG y compris pour y
compris pour moi d'ailleurs là vous
venez de réduire ma CSG parce que je
suis en retraite
vous venez de baisser ma CSG non mais
c'est juste incroyable quoi c'est juste
incroyable voilà ce que vous venez de
faire là vous venez de baisser la CSG
notamment pour les gens les plus aisés
et des gens de la classe moyenne aussi
c'est vrai voilà ce que vous venez de
faire là alors je vais pas le montant
global de la CE combien quelqu'un
milliards
on met ça dans l'escarcelle sur les plus
riches entre sur les plus riches
[Musique]
bah ça a été voté
très bien sur ce je vais mettre au vois
cet amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable s'il vous plaît mes chers
collègues on se calme
qui est pour
qui contre il est rejeté amendement
suivant monsieur Monet
oui madame la Présidente c'est juste un
petit amendement qui veut renforcer la
taxation des retraites de chapeau qui
bénéficient aux dirigeants des grands
entreprises et notamment de les taxé à
21 % au-delà de 10000 euros par mois
juste contribution
à la solidarité nationale je juste un
mot sur le débat qu'on a eu tout à
l'heure d'abord sur la question de la
valeur travail
la question de la valeur travail c'est
d'abord vivre de son travail dignement
c'est ce que nous avons essayé de faire
à travers nos demandes répétés nos
propositions d'augmentation des salaires
qui ont toujours été refusés et
respecter la valeur travail c'est quand
on travaille pouvoir se payer une bonne
retraite et vous faites l'inverse avec
cette réforme et ma deuxième remarque
sous forme de question je pense qu'on
définit les mots et on définit les
choses en fonction de leur inverse on a
parlé tout à l'heure des gens qui
méritent donc je voudrais savoir
toujours savoir pour vous c'est qui ce
qui ne mérite pas et c'est qui ce qui ne
réussissent pas non plus parce qu'on ne
parle de gens qui réussissent moi
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous considérez
comme étant les gens qui ne réussissent
pas
très bien monsieur alors Monsieur
ménager
je vous remercie
donc je demande quand même la vie de
Madame la rapporteur merci
madame la Présidente c'est un avis
défavorable vous voulez augmenter la
taxation de ce qu'on appelle les
retraites chapeau qui sont en fait des
régimes de retraite supplémentaire à
prestation définie financée par
l'employeur je rappelle que sur ces
montants l'employeur est redevable d'une
contribution soit sur les rangs de
servis avec un taux à 32% soit sur les
cotisations patronales avec un taux soit
de 24 soit
48%. je rappelle aussi que ces retraites
chapeau n'engendre en fait que peu de
bénéfices pour les personnes concernées
de tirent des bénéficiaires reçoivent
une rente annuelle
inférieur à 2000 euros et la moitié des
entreprises ayant souscrit un contrat de
retraite vers en moyenne pour chacun de
leurs salariés concernés un montant
inférieur à 2000 euros par an il sera
donc totalement
inefficace pour notre système de
protection sociale d'augmenter la
fiscalité de ce dispositif donc avis des
favorable très bien monsieur ménager je
vous remercie madame présidence alors
nous voterons en faveur de cet
amendement parce que oui c'est retraite
chapeau c'est des dizaines de milliards
d'euros par an rien de justifie ces
retraites aujourd'hui on est dans la
volonté d'avoir une réforme de justice
sociale quand on sait que l'ancien PDG
de L'Oréal c'est 3 millions de retraite
par an l'ancien PDG patron d'Airbus et
1,3 millions d'euros par an nous au
rassemblement national l'objectif c'est
de défendre le peuple défendre ceux qui
travaillent le plus et qui méritent une
retraite digne donc nous ne sommes pas à
compte les milliardaires nous sommes pas
contre les riches mais nous considérons
que les riches ne doivent pas abuser non
plus et qu'il faut bien entendu faire en
sorte que les plus pauvres les plus
modestes ceux qui travaillent le plus
dans notre pays qui ont les métiers les
plus usant eux leur retraite qui
augmente et pas forcément ceux qui ont
déjà la capacité de vivre dignement dans
des conditions très agréables c'est pour
ça que nous voterons dans un esprit non
sectaire contrairement à la nups cette
amendement
très bien monsieur mournay merci madame
la Présidente chers collègues je trouve
que le débat de ce matin est intéressant
parce qu'il nous amène dans le coeur du
sujet donc comment affronter le le
déficit qui est devant nous et là dessus
vous avez parfaitement raison il y a pas
ceux qui ont raison ceux qui ont tort il
y a des débats politiques qui
s'affrontent moi il y a une chose quand
même qui qui m'inquiète un tout petit
peu qui est au fond un débat caché c'est
la fiscalisation croissante du
financement de la branche vieillesse de
la sécurité sociale déjà
les cotisations restent évidemment
majoritaires heureusement mais
sont en part proportionnelle en
diminution notre collègue ils accident
un peu plus tôt nous a rappelé aussi le
le déficit caché des 30 milliards
compensés par l'État et qui ne se voit
pas dans le modalité d'équilibre
permanent des régimes
alors je vais vous dire moi le fond de
ma pensée c'est que les retraites ont
pas grand chose à faire dans la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
d'ailleurs j'avais essayé de travailler
un amendement c'est une loi quinquennale
Haddock malheureusement c'est pas
recevable en l'état de la loi organique
mais nous souhaitons les débats sont
intéressants sur la CSG sur des impôts
nous souhaitons préserver un système de
revenus différé de salaire différé c'est
ça le système par répartition et donc
pour ça il faut un moment donné que sans
interdire des débats sur les impôts
préserver cela ou alors on est dans un
débat caché qui fait glisser de proche
en proche vers finalement une
capitalisation déguisée donc j'ai envie
de dire nous ce que nous souhaitons
faire mais peut-être que c'est ça le
cœur du débat qu'il faut l'affronter
comme ça c'est préserver le système par
répartition avec une solution de travail
et progressivement un peu plus longtemps
pour répartir équitablement le temps
d'espérance de vie en plus sur le
travail et sur la retraite tout ce que
nous débattons depuis ce matin qui sont
des éléments intéressants nous font
sortir un peu plus du système par
répartition et aller mettre les
retraites en concurrence avec d'autres
services publics et il me semble pas que
c'est ce que nous défendons merci très
bien excellent moment de notre collègue
Monet qui prévoit la taxation des
retraites chapeaux qui bénéficient
largement aux dirigeants des grandes
entreprises j'irai même plus loin chers
collègues oui nous sommes pour la
suppression d'un seul régime spécial
celui des retraites chapeau pour rappel
les retraites chapeaux coûtent 43
milliards d'euros par an et ne justifie
en rien ces montants par exemple
1,7 millions pour l'ancien PDG Danone
entre trois millions de retraite par an
pour l'ancien PDG de L'Oréal plutôt que
de supprimer les vrais laissez-moi
parler chers collègues s'il vous plaît
plutôt que de supprimer les vrais
régimes spéciaux qui répondent à des
enjeux de pénibilité supprimons plutôt
les parachutes dorés des plus fortunés
et évitons la mort avant la retraite des
travailleurs essentiels
[Applaudissements]
très bien on évite de s'aplaudir s'il
vous plaît monsieur Daredevil
merci madame la Présidente non c'est
simplement bon je voudrais me féliciter
qu'on est adopté précédemment un
amendement et je regrette que que ça
provoque que le seum de la majorité
parce que franchement faut pas faut pas
le prendre comme ça monsieur alosé on
est là pour discuter un texte on est là
pour faire notre travail de
parlementaire et on est là pour voter un
certain nombre de dispositions
suivez monsieur le député on
s'interpelle pas poursuivait
[Musique]
spécial c'est ça que nous voulons voilà
et donc à l'arrivée le mélange des gens
entre
la cotisation et l'impôt c'est vous qui
l'avez créé les tatisations de la de la
sécurité sociale c'est vous qui l'avez
accéléré vous avez même voulu aller plus
loin que le point où on en est
aujourd'hui donc peut-être que vous le
regrettez et à ce moment-là c'est très
bien et on pourra avoir un débat serein
mais je pense qu'il faut aussi voilà
laisser les choses à leur place et pas
essayer de créer la confusion dans les
esprits
très bien Madame tailler Pollion merci
madame la Présidente oui je m'inscris
complètement dans la dans la lignée de
ce que vient de dire mon collègue
d'arriville il faut arrêter d'essayer
d'embrouiller les gens il vous reste
plus que ça finalement tellement votre
réforme est impossible à expliquer
aux françaises et aux Français vous avez
essayé de de dire que vous étiez juste
et équitable ça marche pas évidemment
parce que votre effort est injuste alors
vous essayez de dire que nous on est
pour la capitalisation et que vous vous
êtes les grands sauveurs les grands
euros du système par répartition c'est
complètement ridicule c'est même c'est
même pathétique en réalité donc il faut
arrêter avec avec cela d'autant plus que
en réalité vous qui affaiblissez sans
arrêt ce système par répartition c'est
vous qui voulez pousser finalement les
Françaises et les Français à chercher
des systèmes compensatoires et à se
tourner vers le privé comme vous le
faites d'ailleurs pour tout ce qui
concerne les services publics dans ce
pays quand vous mettez en place
parcoursup en fait vous retirez l'accès
aux à l'université publique et qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont faire ils vont dans le privé
quand vous affaiblissez l'hôpital public
et les financements continuant avec la
T2A qu'est-ce que vous faites vous
renforcez l'offre de soins privés et les
cliniques privées etc et donc les gens
ils voient le service public qui
s'affaiblit qu'est-ce qu'ils font et
bien logiquement il se tourne vers le
privé quand vous avez réformé la
formation professionnelle vous avez
affaibli le service public de l'AFPA et
vous avez libéralisé avec les super
applis parce qu'on sait que c'est votre
spécialité les applis qu'est-ce qui se
passe et bah écoutez il se passe c'est
que vous avez une explosion une
explosion de de l'offre privée avec tout
et n'importe quoi y compris des arnaques
etc et hop vous renforcez le privé c'est
votre ligne politique de renforcer le
privé donc arrêtez de nous expliquer
parce que c'est c'est vous embrouiller
les choses parce que vous n'avez plus
d'autres lignes de défense donc c'est
pathétique maintenant cessé retirer
cette réforme et puis construisons
l'avenir de la France
très bien Madame la rapporteur général
oui madame la présente je voudrais
revenir sur les propos de Monsieur
d'arriville qui dit que le fait
d'adopter un amendement en fébrile je
crois pas c'est plutôt une
incompréhension parce que je reviens sur
le fait que l'amendement qui a été
adopté et proposé par la nuque bessait
le taux de CSG pour les 25% les plus
riches en rendant la CSG moins
progressive et donc moins juste c'est
juste une certaine forme
d'incompréhension par rapport au
discours
très bien je me permets juste puisque la
formation professionnelle a été évoquée
par Madame tailler polluant juste de
dire que la suite à la réforme il y a eu
un investissement massif massif dans la
formation professionnelle grâce au plan
d'investissement dans les compétences de
15 milliards et c'est ce qui a permis à
des milliers et des milliers et des
milliers de demandeurs d'emploi à des
personnes en situation de vulnérabilité
de pouvoir se former et de faciliter
effectivement leur insertion
professionnelle c'est ce qui a également
permis
d'augmenter le nombre d'apprentis en
France puisque nous sommes passés de 260
000 en 2017 à 720 000 aujourd'hui très
bien alors sur ce je mets on voit cet
amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur
général qui est pour
22 56 qui est contre
il est rejeté
très bien nous arrivons mes chers
collègues à deux amendements
identiques monsieur Guedj vous avez la
parole
[Musique]
madame la Présidente cet amendement
aborde la question des retraites des
retraits de chapeau dans le prolongement
de l'échange que vous nous venons
d'avoir mais par un outil différent
puisqu'il est proposé
d'accroix de significativement la
taxation des retraites chapeau en
conservant le seuil de 24000 euros de
rendement Suelle mais en passant le taux
de 21% à 30% bref c'est un autre moyen
que celui qui avait été retenu donc
peut-être que ça va permettre de faire
évoluer votre position parce que il faut
juste se rappeler de quoi on parle Tom
Anders vous vous rappelez de ce nom
c'était l'ex patron d'Airbus en avril
2019 et c'est lui qui avait relancé le
débat et déclencher l'annonce d'un
projet d'encadrement des retraites
chapeau par le ministre de l'économie de
l'époque Bruno Le Maire pourquoi parce
que Monsieur Henders il devait toucher
une enveloppe globale pouvant atteindre
36,8 millions d'euros à compter de son
départ à la retraite en avril 2019 le
problème que nous avons avec ces
retraites
la peau c'est que
les sommes versées ne donnent pas lieu
puisque il y a une contribution
patronale un peu hallucinante qui est
destiné à compenser
l'impact fiscal pour le bénéficiaire de
la retraite chapeau c'est ça
l'aberration d'aucun disent un
responsable de la CFE-CGC disait que
c'est quasiment de l'abuste bien social
le principe de la retraite chapeau parce
que on verse par l'entreprise une
contribution
dont l'objectif est d'atténuer les
impacts fiscaux du bénéfice de la
retraite chapeau pour le cadre de très
haut niveau ou le dirigeant tient
bénéficient et donc le problème c'est
que cette contribution patronale elle
est exonérée de cotisation de sécurité
sociale de CSG et de CRDS c'est à dire
qu'on a un mécanisme complémentaire sur
complémentaire de retraite qui ne
finance pas la branche vieillesse il ne
finance pas la branche vieillesse et
tout et ce dont je parle là n'est qu'une
mesure compensatoire le vrai sujet et je
rebondis sur ce que disait madame Rista
à l'instant vous nous avez dit qu'il y
avait un système de progressivité de la
CSG sur les pensions de retraite mais là
où je suis d'accord avec vous c'est que
si on va aller réellement au bout d'une
logique de progressivité d'ailleurs
c'est pas une progressivité parce que
c'est des seuils c'est pas de la
progressivité contrairement au seuil de
l'impôt sur le revenu des tranches c'est
des seuils à partir de quels soit en
bénéficient d'un des quatre taux bon
admettons un jour faudra faire une CSG
progressive mais là où je suis d'accord
avec vous c'est que
et 1 à 2 ou 3% de Français qui
bénéficient parce que c'est le cas de
retraite voilà
oui oui mais j'ai deux minutes pour
défendre votre amendement
donc sur ces retraites chapeau à minima
on fait ce qu'on vous propose ici voilà
et derrière on peut avoir une réflexion
plus globale sur la manière dont on met
en place une un taux de CSG pour les
retraites les plus importantes à 12 à 14
à 15% pour réellement introduire de la
CSG progressive on peut pas le faire
dans ce dans un pffs parce que c'est
très bien monsieur le député madame
Rousseau amendement suivant
je vais vous prendre l'exemple de safran
vous allez voir
merci madame la Présidente je vais le
défendre madame taipoliant écoutez on
parle beaucoup effectivement de celles
et ceux qui qui ont plus que les autres
et on a évoqué ensemble la question de
la méritocratie qui sont ces personnes
qui toussent les retraites chapeau ce
sont des personnes qui sont des cadres
supérieurs des cadres supérieurs pour
être quatre supérieurs qu'est-ce qu'il
faut dans notre société mais je vais
vous le dire il faut un père
cadre supérieur ou profession libérale
je vais vous dire j'ai regardé pendant
nos débats la page du gouvernement qui
dit que c'est la profession du père
d'ailleurs à vous noter comme la société
bien faite mais je parle pas de vous je
parle de la société en général excusez
moi votre situation personnelle ne
m'intéresse pas en fait madame la
profession du père joue un rôle majeur
et ce sont les enfants de profession
libérales qui ont une chance sur deux
d'intégrer les 20% les plus aisés puis
viennent les cadres et les chefs d'entre
les enfants de cadres et de chefs
d'entreprise par contre quand vous êtes
fils d'ouvriers d'ouvriers qualifiés
vous avez une chance sur 10 donc il y a
bien là et c'est quelque chose qui est
très cher au président Macron une
inégalité de conditions cette inégalité
de condition il faudrait la revoir et
pour revoir il faudrait rebattre les
cartes et non pas vous accrocher sur une
méritocratie qui n'existe pas qui est
n'est qu'un leur destiné à faire croire
à aux gens que c'est possible alors que
en réalité ce n'est pas possible ce
n'est pas possible et la société est
construite ainsi alors oui passé à 30%
sur les retraites chapeau c'est qu'un
tout petit petit début de début de
remise à plat et pour faire en sorte que
les plus aisés contribuent davantage
très bien Madame la rapporteur général
votre avis sur ces deux amendements
identiques oui c'est un avis défavorable
on a eu le débat je rappelle que les
différents rapports sur ces retraits de
chapeau montrent que deux tiers des
bénéficiaires on 165 euros en moyenne
par mois de rente donc c'est amendement
serait complètement
inefficace et par ailleurs monsieur Gad
il existe bien une contribution
spécifique des employeurs sur ces
retraites qui bénéficient à la sécurité
sociale
franchement
très bien
monsieur Leduc madame Leduc pardon
je vous donne le micro allez-y
oui merci madame la Présidente donc si
on résume avec vous c'est assez simple
faire contribuer les revenus du capital
c'est non faire contribuer les plus
riches c'est non faire contribuer les au
salaire c'est non réorienter les fonds
et maintenant visiblement faire
contribuer les retraites chapeau des PDG
des multinationales c'est non avec vous
c'est toujours non pour trouver des
modes de financement alternatif pour
financer notre régime de retraite mais
voler deux envies aux françaises et aux
Français là c'est un grand oui c'est ça
votre conception d'une réforme juste
vous avez choisi ici entre ceux qui
réussissent et ceux qui ne sont rien et
ces propos sont ce je le rappelle du
président de la République Monsieur
Macron en 2017 donc comme le rappelait
mes collègues le taux de cotisations
appliqué au retrait de chapeau les plus
importantes aujourd'hui et de 21% c'est
moins que les taux de cotisation
appliqués au salaire alors pourquoi
refuser que ces cadeaux financés par les
entreprises aux démes au détriment des
salaires de l'emploi et de
l'investissement contribue plus au
financement de la solidarité
intergénérationnelle la vraie question
qui se pose à nous avec ce texte c'est
celle de la répartition de la richesse
créée la production par tête a été
multipliée par multipliée par 9 depuis
les années 70 la question est de savoir
ce que l'on fait de ce formidable
enrichissement du pays on peut laisser
cette richesse s'accumuler entre
quelques mains par exemple en laissant
les entreprises distribuées de
généreuses retraites chapeau à leur
dirigeants pendant que 99% de la
population continue de se tuer à la
tâche mais une autre voix est possible
avec le formidable accroissement de la
valeur produite sur les 40 dernières
années on peut parfaitement financer une
réduction du temps de travail dans la
journée dans la semaine dans l'année et
dans la vie mais pour vous sinon hors de
question de répartir les richesses les
plus modestes non cabossés deux ans de
plus comment pouvez-vous justifier un
tel dogmatisme avez-vous réellement
allélu allez-vous réellement expliquer
aux aesh aux caissières et aux
aides-soignantes qu'elles vont
travailler deux ans de plus pour que
Bernard Arnault Xavier Niel puisse
toucher sa retraite chapeau
et après vous vous étonnez du rejet que
provoque votre réforme dans le pays
l'opposition à votre projet a gagné
de personnes
présidente
nos débats c'est équilibré nos systèmes
de retraite
je rappelle les chiffres que j'ai vu
tout à l'heure par convention le corps
admet que le régime est diviseur de 30
milliards
par convention le corps admet que le
divisé trois milliards auquel se
surajouterait dans les années qui
arrivent 15 milliards donc on est pour
là pour financer 45 milliards
j'entends j'entends les professions
qu'ils ont faites mais vous nous faites
des propositions pour une meilleure
justice sociale pourquoi pas mais
sincèrement est-ce que sensible en une
ou deux personnes est-ce que
sensiblement les présidents du CAC 40
et ça me fait un petit peu peur dans le
sens où en personnalisant le débat en
montrant du doigt certaines personnes ça
nous rappelle de tristes souvenirs
donc évitons de personnaliser évitons de
montrer des gens du doigt et quelque
part si on récupère quelques millions
peut-être mais là chers collègues il
s'agit de trouver 15 milliards donc tout
ça
ne laissez pas croire aux Français quand
récupérant quelques
millions vous arriverez à équilibrer le
système donc ce sujet hors débat ne
débat c'est comment financer 15
milliards en dehors déjà des 30
milliards
que le corps admet par convention
très bien la parole est à Madame
Rousseau
les plus riches ont une espérance de vie
de 13 ans supérieure aux 5% les plus
pauvres et donc quand on décale l'âge de
la retraite et bien on réduit
mécaniquement l'espérance de vie en
retraite des plus pauvres et si
maintenant on regarde les hommes les
plus pauvres les 40% d'hommes les plus
pauvres et bien en décalant à 64 ans le
nombre de d'hommes qui n'atteindront pas
la retraite augmente de 2% le nombre de
d'hommes qui auront une retraite
inférieure à 5 ans augmente de 4% et
celui qui et ceux qui auront une
retraite inférieure à 10 ans augmente de
près de 10 points et en fait quand on
parle des retraites chapeau on parle
certes des peu de personnes qui les
perçoivent mais on parle de cette espèce
de haut du panier qui finalement
s'émancipe du bien commun c'est-à-dire
qu'ils sont ils ne sont pas taxés ils
sont en général en bénéficient de tout
un tas de
de facilitation de politiques publiques
qui leur permettent tout au long de leur
vie d'avoir les plus grandes largesses
et à la fin sans taxation y compris de
leur retrait de chapeau et bien il y a
une aimant une émancipation du bien
commun une sortie de ce qui devrait être
la norme des inégalités et en fait c'est
à cela qu'on s'adresse quand on pose ses
amendements c'est faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une norme une norme d'égalité que
vraiment il n'y ait pas quelques
individus qui sortent du commun et en
fait c'est un contrat social c'est une
condition de la cohésion sociale et
c'est une condition de justice mais
au-delà du financement c'est
profondément une question philosophique
c'est quel est le degré d'inégalité que
nous sommes prêts à accepter dans la
société et bien je le pose ici je pense
que de notre côté de l'hémicycle il y a
une acceptation des inégalités bien
moins fortes que de votre côté
très bien Madame Vidal
merci madame la Présidente quelques mots
rapides parce que nous avons eu tout à
l'heure un exposé de ce qu'est le
déterminisme familial exposé qui nous
présente cela comme quelque chose
d'absolument incontournable alors ça
existe je ne le nie pas cependant vous
oubliez un point essentiel c'est qu'il
existe aussi quelque chose qui s'appelle
la formation tout au long de la vie et
qui permet à bon nombre d'entre nous de
progresser tout au long de la vie dans
sa carrière avec des formations qui
permettent d'évoluer
considérablement et ça concerne tous les
Français quels qu'ils soient ça concerne
tous les emplois ça existe nous avons
beaucoup travaillé pour cela ça
fonctionne et ça pourra aussi
fonctionner pour celles et ceux qui à un
moment pourront accéder à des formations
pour justement mettre un terme à des
métiers difficiles et s'orienter sur une
fin de carrière sur d'autres métiers
très bien monsieur Guedj
oui merci madame la Présidente
voyez-vous j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
notre rapporteur Stéphanie Rist et pour
mon voisin d'en face Cyril Isa
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les
rapporteur et Siri qu'ils accident mais
je peux vous dire quand même ma petite
déception pour ne pas dire ma grande
déception de vous voir
défenseur zélé d'un système dont vous
savez viscéralement qu'il est injuste
aujourd'hui et donc je suis d'accord
avec avec vous monsieur Isaki ça va pas
générer de quoi équilibrer à elle toute
seule
cette mesure le déséquilibre du système
de retraite mais je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure tous les amendements qu'on vous
propose aujourd'hui ce sont des petits
ruisseaux qui font la grande rivière il
y a pas une mesure vous vous prenez une
mesure qui est l'impôt sur la vie de
tous les travailleurs pour équilibrer le
déficit qu'on ne conteste pas nous ne
vous proposons une palette de mesure et
notamment celle qui sont matricées par
la justice sociale et donc que vous
soyez là à nous expliquer que les
retraites chapeau bah c'est pas grave
c'est pas grave on l'admet moi je vais
vous dire une chose j'ai pas de problème
avec les millionnaires j'ai pas de
problème avec les milliardaire plus il y
en aura dans ce pays plus ça voudrait
dire qu'on créera de la richesse mais
par contre j'ai un problème avec le fait
qu'il ne contribue pas à la hauteur de
leurs moyens à la au partage et à la
redistribution et donc en soustrayant
ces retraites chapeau à la moyenne de
l'effort qui est fait par l'ensemble de
nos de nos concitoyens là aussi vous
avez une mesure qui est incompréhensible
incompréhensible
je vous rappelle que les salariés le
pardon que les patrons du CAC 40 contre
lesquels je n'ai rien encore mais ils
ont quand même doublé en moyenne
annuelle leur salaire il était de 4
millions et demi en 2020 il est passé à
8,7 millions en 2021 qu'on a donc ce
mécanisme des retraites chapeau et je le
redis de cette de ce dispositif et que
donc en les protégeant vous envoyez un
signal désastreux qui est de dire
l'effort c'est pour le plus grand nombre
et pas pour quelques-uns la parole est à
Monsieur ménager merci à la présidente
bon moi pas clairement je vous le dis
j'en ai ras-le-bol qu'on ne traite pas
du fond de cette réforme j'ai vraiment
l'impression que ça vous arrange la
majorité d'avoir la nupes au milieu
utile d'avoir la nups qui fait
l'obstruction ça vous arrange mais oui
comme dirait madame Guichard vous avez
vous avez fait le choix de cette réforme
assumez comme Madame Guichard qui
méprise les aesh vous assumez assumez
d'avoir fait le choix du report de deux
ans de 62 à 64 ans et parlons-en
pourquoi vous voulez pas en parler
pourquoi vous refusez de retirer vos
amendements pourquoi vous refusez le
pour un compte pourquoi vous c'est
l'examen prioritaire pourquoi vous
refusez de parler du fond de la réforme
dans quelques heures cette commission
s'arrête on aura traité de rien du tout
rien de ce qui intéresse les Français
c'est quand même incroyable mais c'est
incroyable vous demandez aux Français
d'assumer vous demander aux assumer mais
vous vous n'assumez rien vous assumez
pas votre réforme vous voulez pas en
parler mais madame ça fait des heures
vous utilisez laupède vous utilisez ces
idiots utiles qui bloquent le débat vous
les utilisez pour éviter de parler du
fond du sujet
qui attendent que nous parlions qui
attendent que nous parlions de ce report
de l'âge légal de savoir comment ils
vont réussir à assumer ces deux ans de
plus vous vous avez des métiers plutôt
agréables pour la plupart vous êtes
députés vous êtes ici vous êtes au chaud
il y a des Français qui sont dehors il y
a des employés du bâtiment des
Carreleurs des maçons des couvreurs qui
sont sur le terrain qui sont en train de
se cailler les miches et qui attendent
de savoir comment ils vont aller de 62 à
64 ans donc est-ce qu'on peut parler du
sujet est-ce qu'on peut parler de cette
question qui les intéresse plutôt que
s'amuser avec la nupestre parce que vous
vous amusez avec la nuit pêche vous
utilisez notre best et eux ils sont bien
contents parce qu'ils veulent donner
l'impression d'être utile monsieur le
député ne dites pas cela s'il vous plaît
ne faites pas les questions et les
réponses à la place de la majorité s'il
vous plaît très bien alors non monsieur
bazar vous avez la parole
oui merci madame la présidente madame le
rapportant mes chers collègues il faut
qu'on fasse attention parce que la
situation
la question des retraites est très
complexe et elle varie d'ailleurs en
fonction des situations en fonction des
métiers en fonction des secteurs or j'ai
l'impression parfois qu'on généralise
tous les cas mais il ne se correspondent
pas si on prend un certain nombre de
métiers pénible et on doit être soucieux
de cette pénibilité je pense notamment
aux catégories actives et super active
elles ne sont pas concernées à ma
connaissance par l'allongement après on
a un sujet sur le rapport au travail
quand l'âge avance et d'ailleurs ça ne
se pose pas qu'entre 62 et 64 je suis
pas sûr que le fait de travailler
accélère la mort
enfin je suis pas docteur mais je vous
posais un postulat qui interroge et il
devrait davantage
nous interpeller sur la question de la
santé au travail et et c'est une cause
très importante et de la place de
l'activité et je sais bien je le dis
devant vous rapporte cher rapporteur
général c'est que l'activité participe
aussi à maintenir une santé l'activité
par permet aussi de s'épanouir
l'activité voilà alors c'est sûr que
tout est-ce que tout travail est pénible
non
et et heureusement il y a certains
métiers et il faut les reconnaître les
adapter prévenir qui qui sont pénibles
profondément mais on a des métiers qui
qui ne sont pas forcément synonymes
d'accélération de la mort et je crois
qu'il faut faire attention dans la
manière de présenter les choses bien sûr
il faut accompagner il faut prévenir
voire même anticiper avec des
reconversions des changements
sur la carrière en fin de carrière
permettent les retraites progressives
c'est sûr que le travail de nuit les
séquences il y a un certain nombre de le
critères à apprendre en compte mais j'ai
l'impression en vous écoutant que que
toute personne qui travaille
en ayant passé un certain âge finalement
ça nurait à sa santé c'est pas
exactement tout le monde très bien
monsieur le député donc après ce débat
je vais mettre aux voix à moins que
Madame la rapporteur soit dire quelque
chose oui merci madame la Présidente
quand même redire un mot déjà pour ce
que dit Monsieur Bazin moi j'ai très
envie qu'on aille sur l'article 9 qui
permettrait de parler de la pénibilité
ce d'autant qu'on fait une véritable
révolution de la prévention et je le dis
dans ce texte sur la pénibilité qui
permettra aux gens certes de partir pour
ceux qui le peuvent plus tard mais en
meilleure forme et pour répondre à
Monsieur ménager on essaye d'avancer la
majorité n'a pas déposé énormément
d'amendements et quand j'essaye de dire
qu'on a déjà eu le débat c'était le cas
très longuement sur l'article 2 on me
demande de de dire que c'est enfin on me
dit que c'est pas bien de pas avoir le
débat donc
la responsabilité en tout cas et
d'essayer de répondre à chacun des
amendements très bien Madame la
rapporteur général je mets aux voix ces
deux amendements qui ont reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur qui
est pour
qui est contre
il est rejetés amendement
identique monsieur Guedj
on va évoquer
un autre trou dans la raquette du
financement
de la branche vieillesse c'est la
question des actions gratuites
depuis le mécanisme AGA ce qui veut dire
fiscalité sur la tribution gratuite
d'action alors qui a été créé je préfère
le dire tout de suite parce que ça va
nous être envoyé à figure par une loi de
c'était la loi Macron l'article 34
oui oui mais café
baissé qui a réduit la fiscalité de ses
Agats de 30 à 20%
. et c'était une sorte d'incitation aux
entreprises à recourir à ce à ce à ce
dispositif en allégeant le niveau de
fiscalité c'était rappelez-vous la
mesure phare de la start-up nation avec
cette idée que ça va permettre aux
jeunes pousses de devoir le jour moi mon
problème c'est que quand on regarde un
peu les rechercher pareil un petit
ruisseau qui font les grandes rivières
c'est 125 millions d'euros de moins pour
la sécurité sociale et singulièrement
pour la branche pour la branche
vieillesse et personne je dis bien
personne ne peut établir une corrélation
entre la baisse de la taxation de ces
actions gratuites et une quelconque
dynamique pour la création d'entreprise
pire et je peux pas m'empêcher de faire
le lien avec des mécanismes d'actualité
ça a donné lieu à des graves dérives
ORPEA mes chers collègues Yves Leman le
patron d'Orpea qui a été limogé quelque
chose ont été rendus publics non
seulement il avait un salaire fixe de
712000 euros il avait un salaire
variable de 464000 euros mais il avait
également des actions gratuites versées
sur trois ans et conditionner à
l'atteinte de certains objectifs je n'ai
pas besoin de vous mentionner quels
étaient les objectifs c'était estimé à
760000 euros donc voyez bien que c'était
pas pour la startup nation mais c'était
y compris pour des pans qui
malheureusement avait atteint un tel
niveau de financiarisation de leur
activité que ce mécanisme là était parti
prenante de la rémunération y compris
quand elle était motivée par des
éléments par des éléments cupides donc
qui est des actions gratuites pour aider
à l'émergence à son entreprise pas de
problème mais si on revenait simplement
au niveau de taxation avant la loi
madame Rousseau vous avez la parole
et bien je vais poursuivre ce que dit
mon collègue puisque c'est sur la même
sur la même le même dispositif et en
l'occurrence en effet avoir des actions
gratuites c'est réservé à une petite
partie de la population tout le monde
n'en bénéficie pas et en plus ça a été
un dispositif donc pierre d'arriville
rappelait tout à l'heure qu'il a été
voté un peu une extrémie son dernier en
dernière intention à la faveur de l'un
de ces moments dans l'assemblée que l'on
connaît ou on peut renverser un vote
comme ça au dernier moment et donc là il
s'agit juste encore une fois de rétablir
un tout petit peu de justice pas
beaucoup hein c'est pas énorme enfin
quand même déjà un petit bout de justice
qui consisterait à dire que finalement
avoir des actions gratuites c'est soumis
à un système fiscal voilà c'est pas
c'est pas révolutionnaire mais c'était
un petit ruisseau
très bien Madame la député monsieur
dareville ou monsieur Monet
il a défendu tout à l'heure donc défendu
très bien merci monsieur le député
madame la rapporteur votre avis sur ces
trois amendements
avis avis défavorable madame la
Présidente
très bien alors Monsieur Vigier vous
avez la parole non non je vous avais
inscrit monsieur Clouet
madame la Présidente comme dans beaucoup
d'amendements qui précèdent on est un
petit peu interloqué par le fait que
vous refusez de l'argent c'est quand
même très étonnant on arrive avec un
bout de papier qu'on appelle un
amendement ce bout de papier il
suffirait de le voter la charge la
pénibilité l'activité de députés quand
même assez faible et simplement en
levant la main vous auriez 125 millions
d'euros rajouter dans les caisses de
l'assurance vieillesse et c'est quand
même d'autant plus intéressant que vous
pourriez par la même non seulement
permettre d'abonder des fonds mais
également revenir sur vos propres
erreurs avec les lois Macron des années
2015 qui montre que par ailleurs on
n'est pas rancunier on vous propose de
revenir sur vos propres erreurs c'est
dire à quel point on est dans la
co-construction puisque ces actions
gratuites on le sait bien elle consiste
à rémunérer les salariés le monde du
travail par autre chose que leur salaire
s'il est rémunéré par un titre qui
lui-même a une rentabilité et les
rendements
occasionnés par les titres sont
affranchis ou en tout cas ont un système
de de non pas fiscalité mais de
contribution on veut dire plus faible
que les revenus du travail donc il
s'agit de rééquilibrer de faire la
justice sociale faire en sorte que le
salaire et l'action gratuite rapporte
aux Caisses d'Assurance Vieillesse dans
les deux cas pour une raison simple
c'est que l'action si elle a une valeur
c'est grâce au travail des salariés de
l'entreprise donc en fait toute la
valeur qui est gagnée par le biais de la
propriété d'une action gratuite et tirée
du travail d'autrui et donc à partir de
là il est normal que le travail étant la
source de toute valeur toute forme de
rendement basée sur le travail
directement ou indirectement viennent
contribuer à l'assurance vieillesse bref
ce qui se joue ici en montant le forfait
social de 20 à 30%, c'est de récupérer
125 millions d'euros et ce d'autant plus
vous le savez chers collègues que dans
beaucoup d'entreprises les plans
d'action gratuite ne bénéficient pas et
de moins en moins aux salariés ils vont
de plus en plus souvent au personnel de
direction c'était le cas encore
récemment à sopra par exemple où les
plans prévisionnels d'action gratuites
mieux rémunérer que l'inflation ont été
alloués au personnel de direction alors
que les salariés eux voyaient leur
pouvoir d'achat rogner bref il s'agit de
faire trois choses
justice salariale très bien monsieur le
député madame Garet Garin pardon vous
avez la parole merci madame la
Présidente pour venir en soutien de cet
amendement mais aussi pour réagir aux
propos qui ont été tenus un peu plus tôt
notamment en réponse à Monsieur Bazin
mais qu'est-ce qui accélère la mort
aujourd'hui ce qui est accélère la mort
aujourd'hui c'est la pénibilité au
travail c'est la maladie au travail avec
l'absence de prévention et l'absence de
santé au travail et c'est aussi la
précarité parce que l'espérance de vie
des travailleurs les plus pauvres elle
est inférieur à celle des travailleurs
les plus aisés et souvent les deux vont
ensemble on a souvent des travailleurs
qui sont les plus pauvres qui ont les
métiers les plus pénibles et j'entendais
aussi tout à l'heure dans les rangs de
la majorité que finalement je sais pas
si grave d'avoir un métier pénible
puisqu'à un moment donné il va y avoir
une formation il y aura une reconversion
et tout ira bien mais quid de évocation
il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont dans
des métiers pénibles par vocation quick
de la passion en fait au travail vous
nous défendez le travail tout le temps
mais on a le droit de l'aimer son
travail on a le droit d'y vouloir y
passer sa vie si on y est bien mais à
condition d'y être bien
et quand vous me dites ça moi j'ai
l'impression finalement d'entendre une
musique des corps jetables qu'on épuise
et qu'après on met on jette et on met de
côté et en fait c'est je trouve ça
profondément choquant et au lieu de
prendre en compte la question
effectivement de la pénal de la
pénibilité et de revaloriser ces métiers
et je pense notamment au métier qui sont
en première ligne et au métier du soin
qui sont à 80 % des métiers qui sont
occupés par des femmes mais finalement
ça nous montre à quel point vous êtes à
côté de la plaque avec ce projet de loi
bien Madame la Députée mais je ne crois
pas avoir entendu quelqu'un dans cette
commission tout bord confondu avoir dit
ça n'est pas grave d'avoir un travail
aussi pénible personne je l'ai pas
entendu une seule fois je ne l'ai pas
entendu du tout très bien Madame
Parmentier Lecoq vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente on arrive
merci ma présence non je vais dire on
arrive là à l'issue de notre séance de
débat de la matinée et j'aimerais faire
un petit point sur où on en est je pense
qu'on a quand même bien avancé ce matin
puisque maintenant
la nups acte qui a vraiment un problème
de déficit qui a un problème financier
sur le système de financement de des
retraits donc on a quand même fait un
pas
Isaac qui a un problème de financement
que nous propose-t-il pour régler ce
problème de financement
comme d'habitude j'allais dire plus de
taxes plus d'impôts plus de cotisations
j'aimerais que la nups nous trouve un
jour un pays où on taxe plus on prélève
plus que la France et ou en même temps
on finance des retraites avec un départ
à 60 ans tout en prenant le droit à la
paresse tout au long de la vie à mon
avis n'existe pas donc c'est un projet
encore une fois totalement chimérique et
inefficace que nous propose de l'URN à
ce stade va toujours aucune proposition
si ce n'est
si ce n'est les habituels rengaines
xénophobes bien typique de l'extrême
droite c'est-à-dire mettre le mettre sur
le dos des étrangers est-ce que ce sont
les étrangers vraiment qui coûtent 30
milliards d'euros par an au système des
retraites il faut quand même arrêter de
raconter n'importe quoi donc en
conclusion à l'issue de ces débats on a
aucun aucun projet aucun contre projet
réaliste on a juste deux contre projets
totalement
inefficaces et tout aussi inefficace que
populiste
très bien monsieur Bazin
oui merci madame la Présidente et merci
pour la précision que vous avez pu déjà
opérer ma chère collègue
j'ai jamais parlé de corps jetable et
c'est pas ma conception pour pour ceux
qui voilà je
suis trop attaché à la dignité de chaque
personne voilà ce que je voulais juste
te dire dans mon propos c'est que il y a
des métiers pénibles et il y a des
métiers pénibles et il y en a qui qui le
sont moins c'est une réalité
sur les métiers pénibles qui souvent
correspondent aux catégories actives et
super active on a des métiers pénibles
qui ne sont pas dedans et il faut
regarder mais sur les catégories actives
et et super active là je n'augmente pas
la durée d'exposition ne demande pas
c'est vraiment une bonne chose et
heureusement que ça soit pas le cas sur
ce qui n'entre pas dans ce champ là mais
pourtant des métiers je pense par
exemple dans la fonction publique au
contractuelle il y a près de 100 000
aide-soignantes contractuelles elles
sont pas éligibles au C2P elles sont pas
éligible
aux catégories actives on voit bien
qu'il y a des dispositions à prendre en
compte pour améliorer cette prise en
compte de la pénibilité alors je pense
qu'il faut qu'on fasse attention dans
nos débats parce que en général ils ont
tout on peut peut-être se tromper de
cible il faut qu'on puisse s'adapter aux
réalités des métiers les prévenir
anticiper on a un vrai défi sur la santé
au travail on manque de médecins au
travail il y a un vrai sujet sur la
prévention
mon collègue était ancien qu'on
rapporteur de la de la broche ATMP le
sait bien on on a sur la mobilisation
des fonds sur l'accident du travail m'a
dit professionnel il y a un fond qui est
promis sur le côté soignant il faut
qu'on aille sur les autres métiers qui
sont pas forcément soignants et je pense
sincèrement de catégories actives de la
fonction publique pour le coup où il y a
pas de fond spécifique par rapport à ça
et comment le finance comment on
construit ça comment on fait de la
prévention je suis d'accord avec vous
sur un certain nombre de de trous dans
la raquette faut qu'on améliore la donne
mais c'est tout métier n'est pas pénible
voilà je crois que c'est important de
préciser très bien très bien monsieur le
député monsieur Vigier oui merci la
présidente comme je disais d'ailleurs
très bien Madame ma collègue à l'instant
je crois qu'à la fin de cette matinée il
y a quelques enseignements le premier
c'est lui-même dans la voie quand même
une certaine autorité au sein de la
nippe vous reconnaissez tous enfin que
les systèmes de retraite n'est pas
équilibré et que donc ça n'est pas une
réforme que l'on fait uniquement pour se
faire plaisir mais qu'il faut une
réforme je crois que c'est une avancée
et me semble-t-il en termes de pédagogie
vis-à-vis de concitoyens c'est important
moi je vais faire vous voyez comme votre
collègue Ruffin nous demande avec un peu
de douceur il a dit ça dans un média
hier je l'ai écouté donc il faut aussi
un peu de douceur dans ce que l'on vient
de dire à l'instant à l'instant Thibault
Bazin pareil de la pénibilité nous ne
pouvons pas entendre que vous êtes les
Gentils qui vous occupez de la
pénibilité que nous sommes les méchants
nous en occupons pas ça ça n'est pas
acceptable vous n'avez pas le monopole
la pénibilité nous serons là pour le
rappeler la troisième chose je voudrais
dire aux collègues ménager que je
regarde il nous accuse d'étalier
objectif de la nuit PSP pardonnez-moi
c'est pas nous qui avons décidé de
déposer 7000 amendements ne lui
reprochez pas ce que nous n'avons pas
fait ou alors peut-être je vois déjà ce
profilé un peu le débat du lundi matin
si j'ai bien compris vous partirez pas
le week-end ensemble et j'ai bien
compris aussi que lundi matin vous aurez
peut-être du mal à associer vos voix les
uns avec les autres si vous êtes
cohérent avec vous-même enfin
le dernier mot par rapport aux actions
gratuites je dis à Jérôme Guedj
évidemment avec son art consommé d'aller
chercher toujours l'épine là où il est
il a en parlant d'orpa une épine qui est
réelle et je crois qu'on était tous
ensemble pour dénoncer ce qui s'est
passé les Coréa mais les actions
gratuites le partenariat la
participation dans l'entreprise fruit me
semble-t-il là encore de l'héritage des
45 et plutôt une belle avancée sur
laquelle on peut se retrouver je tiens à
rassurer tout le monde c'est pas lundi
matin c'est on se retrouve l'après-midi
à 16h non mais certains commençaient à
angoisser donc je vous le dis
très bien très bien mais chers député
non mais je voyais un peu les angoisses
montées alors Monsieur frappé et lui
seul à la parole
oui merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais qu'on revienne sur l'amendement
avec l'attribution des actions gratuites
donc le but de cet amendement est
d'augmenter la fiscalité sur ces actions
gratuites mais je voudrais rappeler que
au-delà de la participation dans
l'entreprise l'attribution d'actions
gratuites et a pour but de fidéliser les
salariés de l'entreprise mais aussi de
leur accorder des revenus
complémentaires donc je pense que
augmenter la fiscalité de ce serait
peut-être un effet néfaste sur ces
actions initiales merci
très bien monsieur le député monsieur
Guedj et respecter les deux minutes
parce qu'à chaque fois
mes chers
d'éléments de langage du moment
[Musique]
parce que nous sommes des lecteurs
attentifs du corps
nous n'avons jamais contesté et je dis
bien jamais donc vous vous mettez ça au
crédit des discussions qui sont ici nous
n'avons jamais contesté l'existence d'un
déficit conjoncturel sur une sur une
durée sur une s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît parce qu'après je crame mon temps
à cause de vous voilà donc nous ne
l'avons jamais contesté nous contestons
les réponses que vous apportez alors sur
les montants le corps nous dit 12
milliards à partir de 2027 et avec une
montée en puissance qui va tangente 22 à
25 milliards d'euros au plus fort de la
période nous ne le contestons pas à
aucun moment nous contestons la réponse
simpliste et par des mois de le dire un
peu paresseuse qui consiste à faire
travailler tout le monde deux ans de
plus en levant cette impôt sur la vie
plutôt que des chercher des solutions
alternatives et depuis ce matin nous
vous proposons des solutions
alternatives et moi je suis à bassourdi
par le fait que notamment quand ces
solutions et elles sont c'est pas de
toutes s'inscrivent dans une logique de
justice sociale c'est-à-dire de mettre à
contribution soit les retraites chapeau
soit les actions gratuites et je vous le
dis nous allons après l'article 3 vous
faire des séries de propositions pour
soumettre à cotisation d'assurance
vieillesse dépend entier de rémunération
qui ont échappé au fil du temps il y a
des pans entiers de rémunération et de
revenus qui ne financent pas le système
de retraite il suffirait de les intégrer
dans l'assiette des cotisations pour que
le déficit de celui-ci soit
considérablement atténué et donc vous
allez être de plus en plus en difficulté
pour dire que
il n'y a pas d'autres solutions que
celle que vous proposez depuis ce matin
et je termine par là c'est déjà 500
millions d'euros de recettes
complémentaires que vous avez refusé 500
millions sur les 12 milliards
mais c'est déjà mieux que rien et vous
verrez
cette longue discussion
donc ils sont identiques donc je les
mets aux voix ils ont reçu tous les
trois un avis de défavorable qui est
pour
qui est contre ils sont rejetés
amendement pouvant être mis en
discussion communes
[Musique]
très bien Madame la Présidente aucun
problème merci beaucoup effectivement je
vais vous présenter les amendements 70
et 79 de Madame SAS dans cette
députée vous dites 70 60
nous avons nous avons nous portons une
autre proposition qui est de
créer une contribution additionnelle à
la C3S c'est la contribution sociale de
solidarité des sociétés dont le produit
serait affecté à la CNAV cette
contribution additionnelle
représenterait le double de celui de
l'actuel C3S soit 9,2 milliards d'euros
et nous avons commandement de repli
cette contribution est d'autant plus
réalisable que les entreprises ont
bénéficié de 14 milliards d'euros de
baisse d'impôts de production faut-il le
rappeler sans contrepartie alors moi je
voudrais aussi m'inscrire dans la dans
le débat là effectivement on essaie de
tirer des enseignements le premier
enseignement fantaisiste serait que la
gauche et les écologistes pour la
capitalisation et le second enseignement
fantaisiste de cette matinée serait que
nous aurions nié le sujet de financement
des quelques années à venir mais à
réponse à problème conjoncturel réponse
conjoncturelle un problème structurel
réponse structurelle là nous sommes face
à une question qui est d'ordre
conjoncturel et donc pour répondre à ce
problème temporaire et relatif parce que
quand on regarde par rapport aux pips
c'est vraiment pas grand chose vous
sortez les grands les grands moyens
alors là vraiment pour réparer le toit
vous vous brisez la maison quoi donc non
non nous sommes
toutes les propositions qu'il faut pour
résoudre ce problème conjoncturel et
nous souhaitons donc faire en sorte que
notre système soit préservé et même
améliorer parce qu'aujourd'hui avec
votre réforme vous allez alourdir les
inégalités notamment en celles des
femmes celle que subissent les femmes et
nous nous avons plein de propositions
pour financer et le maintien du système
et aussi son amélioration qui est
urgente et nécessaire
très bien Madame la rapporteur votre
avis sur ces deux amendements c'est un
avis défavorable à ces 3S à augmenter
fortement en 2022 à 4,3 milliards
d'euros ça c'est en raison d'une
politique favorable aux investissement
et à l'emploi donc avis défavorable très
bien Madame La Valette vous avez la
parole merci Madame madame la présidente
madame madame Parmentier le coq
excusez-moi mais je rebondis quand même
grand temps nous n'avons aucune leçon à
recevoir de structure ruines et la
France je vous rappelle que vous avez
quand même laissé 600 milliards de
dettes et vous venez de voter un budget
à 150 milliards de déficit vous avez des
industrialisés le pays je vous rappelle
que vous avez vendu Alstom aux
Américains Alcatel aux Suédois lafargeau
Suisse ce sont juste les emplois qui
nous manquent pour créer de la richesse
et nous n'en serions pas là petit de le
compte projet de Marine Le Pen est
disponible partout il faudrait
travailler un peu et je peux vous dire
que notre il est juste contrairement au
vôtre et si vous n'aviez pas eu la
lâcheté de choisir ce véhicule
législatif peut-être auriez-vous laissé
de le décliner et réveillez-vous en de
la majorité des Français n'en veulent
pas de votre réforme et figurez-vous que
la majorité des députés non plus donc on
comprend bien que vous vouliez faire
traîner le débat avec la complicité de
la mupestre mais les Français nous
regardent et ça ne vous honneur pas très
bien j'aurais aimé que avoir votre avis
sur ses amendements monsieur Léman
merci madame la Présidente bon là on a
un amendement je suis par ailleurs je
vous présente mes excuses parce que je
suis parti tout à l'heure pendant un
petit moment pour accueillir notre
camarade René Pilato et élu pour bloquer
la retraite à 64 ans à la place de
Thomas Meunier qui lui était pour la
retraite à 64 ans donc c'est une bonne
nouvelle j'en viens l'amendement j'en
viens à l'amendement si vous me
permettez mais laissez un peu un peu de
joie pour notre côté quand même nous
avons donc un amendement
si le calme revient ah écoutez nous
sommes un peu piquant c'est tout
nous avons ici un amendement qui propose
donc de relever cette contribution à
accrochez-vous parce que le taux doit
faire peur à tous les grands
capitalistes
0,032 % oh là là quelle catastrophe une
imposition scandaleuse qui va sans doute
ruiner nos entreprises on passerait de
0,7
0,016 à 0,032 et combien ça rapporte
exactement de passer de 0,016 à
0,032 ça rapporte 4,6 milliards d'euros
vous savez moi je trouve qu'en réalité
nos collègues des vers et de générations
ils sont plutôt gentils parce qu'on
aurait pu passer ça à 0,0 64% et là vous
auriez vos 12 milliards d'euros que vous
allez gratter en prenant deux ans de vie
à des Français que vous allez gratter en
envoyant 4000 personnes de la génération
nées en 1968 au cimetière avant d'avoir
atteint la retraite voilà la violence de
ce que vous êtes en train de faire et
quand il y a 2,8 millions de personnes
dans la rue qui sont en train de vous le
dire vous répondez désolé vous n'avez
pas compris vous répondez il va falloir
faire de la pédagogie enfin franchement
collègue un peu de décence un peu
d'humanité voter cet amendement et
peut-être même en séance votez-le un peu
augmenté très bien pour faire en sorte
de gagner faire gagner de la vie plutôt
que de d'en faire perdre
madame la Présidente
on a entendu deux trois trucs qui
méritent d'être relevé
le premier c'est sur le sujet de la
dimension conjoncturelle parce qu'on a
entendu ça on aura un déficit
conjoncturel bon on est à peu près sur
20 milliards de déficits programmés à
minima sur 25 ans ça c'est vraiment
l'hypothèse la plus optimiste du corps
vraiment si on arrive pleine emploi et
autres
perspectives de productivité proche de
proche de l'imaginaire bon ça fait 500
milliards de déficits cumulés d'ici 30
ans on est un tout petit peu au-delà je
pense du sujet conjoncturel on est bien
sur un sujet structurel ensuite
j'entends encore une fois les
écologistes
être d'une mauvaise foi absolue sur le
sujet de la retraite par répartition
vous ne voulez pas l'entendre que vous
voulez sortir mais le principe de la
réforme de la retraite pardon par
répartition c'est extrêmement simple ce
sont les personnes qui travaillent
aujourd'hui qui cotisent pour les
personnes qui sont à la retraite
aujourd'hui c'est d'ailleurs c'est c'est
une limpidité absolue quand vous
financez ce système autrement par de
l'impôt par de l'emprunt par du déficit
vous sortez du principe par répartition
non non c'est limpide on écoute monsieur
le député on a un problème de
vocabulaire faut juste que vous
travaillez sur le sujet et enfin
l'absurdité du rassemblement national et
la sortie de Madame La Valette
franchement on marche sur la tête vous
avez aucun projet vous osez nous parler
de déficit il y a encore quelques
semaines vous étiez sur une retraite à
60 ans 85 milliards là vous êtes restés
sur un modèle à 62 ans on sait pas trop
pourquoi on sait pas trop comment vous
êtes dans le flou absolu
c'est quand même 17 milliards encore une
fois d'ici 10 ans et quand elle a rien
d'industrialisation du pays on a aucune
leçon à recevoir grâce à notre majorité
c'est la première fois depuis 30 ans
qu'on crée des emplois industriels en
France et qu'on crée des usines donc un
tout petit peu d'humidité très bien tu
en applaudit pas s'il vous plaît
monsieur Vigier non en écoutant le
connecter une chose il a très bien
expliqué le problème la retraite Paris
partition c'est qu'à l'heure actuelle le
taux de couverture
c'est 79% en clair il y a déjà 20% qui
sont financés par d'autres mécaniques de
financement 20% de 340 milliards
c'est-à-dire 70 milliards et on va aller
chercher où notamment dans la CSG et
notamment dans les fractions de TVA
voilà la réalité du terrain donc si vous
voulez aller au bout du chemin et 100%
de couverture vous annoncez ici même ce
matin l'assemblée nationale que vous
augmentez les cotisations patronales et
salariales de 20%. je pense que la
presse va apprécier très bien sur ce mes
chers collègues madame la rapporteur
vous souhaitez dire un mot oui merci je
voudrais de façon républicaine féliciter
Monsieur Pilato mais excusez ici
excusez-moi ici dans cette commission de
regretter monsieur meunier qui m'a
précédé au poste de rapporteur général
et qui a honoré cette place en
travaillant beaucoup et faisant des
propositions concrètes pour nos
concitoyens
très bien je partage les propos de
Madame la rapporteur général concernant
Thomas Meunier pour qui nous avons une
pensée émue alors sur ce je vais mettre
aux voix ces deux amendements qui ont
reçu un avis défavorable qui est pour
oui déjà le 79 qui est pour qui est
contre
il est rejeté même à vie même vote très
bien je vous remercie mes chers
collègues et nous nous retrouvons à 15h
cet après-midi
en attendant excellent appétit